Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. As Hercules in days gone by took out his mighty club and got his rubber Nilo down to give the floors a scrub. So forward, Harold, once again to purge the stable's filth, your tiny mandate in your hand and redistribute the wealth. So that was Mrs. Wilson, Harold Wilson's wife, Harold Wilson, the new prime minister in March, 1974. And Dominic, that comes from Private Eye,
感谢您收听《历史就是这样》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。正如赫拉克勒斯在过去挥舞着他那根强有力的棍棒，让他的尼罗河橡胶靴去刷洗地板一样。所以，哈罗德，再次前进吧，去清除马厩里的污秽，手里拿着你那微小的授权，重新分配财富。所以，那是威尔逊夫人，哈罗德·威尔逊的妻子，哈罗德·威尔逊，1974年3月的新任首相。多米尼克，那段话来自《私家侦探》（Private Eye），
which is a satirical magazine run by sniggering public schoolboys, isn't it? Oh no, Tom. That's how it's always described. Shocking scenes. And they have this kind of ongoing thing, don't they, where they have maybe a spouse is commenting on the travails and affairs of a prime minister. So they did it with Mrs. Thatcher. They had Dennis Thatcher writing to Bill Deeds, who was what was he, the head of the Daily Telegraph or something. But in this case, this is Mrs. Wilson's diary. And Mrs. Wilson, the whole point about her, so she's an amateur poet, is that right? She was indeed. Yes,
那是一本由爱窃笑的公立学校男生经营的讽刺杂志，不是吗？哦，不，汤姆。它一直都是这样被描述的。令人震惊的场景。他们有一种持续不断的套路，不是吗？比如让配偶评论首相的辛劳和事务。所以他们在撒切尔夫人身上也这么做了。他们让丹尼斯·撒切尔写信给比尔·迪兹，他当时是什么来着，《每日电讯报》的主编还是什么的。但在这种情况下，这是威尔逊夫人的日记。而威尔逊夫人，关于她最重要的一点，她是一位业余诗人，对吧？她确实是。是的，
she was a very keen amateur poet, Mary Wilson. And she had no interest in politics whatsoever. And this is quite a significant factor of the story we're going to be telling today, isn't it? Because in a sense, Harold Wilson has a kind of political wife. He does indeed. And the degree to which this political wife is fulfilling other marital duties is something we may come on to. But anyway, that's by the by. Yeah. Mrs. Wilson there, and she is urging Harold to get on there.
她是一位非常热衷的业余诗人，玛丽·威尔逊。她对政治毫无兴趣。这是我们今天要讲的故事中一个相当重要的因素，不是吗？因为在某种意义上，哈罗德·威尔逊有一位所谓的“政治妻子”。他确实有。而这位政治妻子在多大程度上履行了其他婚姻职责，是我们可能会谈到的。但无论如何，那是题外话。是的。威尔逊夫人就在那里，她正在敦促哈罗德行动起来。
He's got a tiny mandate, but he's got to redistribute the wealth. And I guess there's a kind of inherent tension there, isn't there? There is indeed. There is indeed. So hello, everybody. Welcome back to 1974. So the date is Monday, the 4th of March. That's where we ended last time with Harold Wilson returning as prime minister after this tumultuous it would be fun to talk about what was actually in the papers that day. What was in the newspapers to give you a sort of snapshot of the flavour of national life. If you go through the sort of small print of the papers,
他只有微小的授权，但他必须重新分配财富。我想这其中有一种内在的张力，不是吗？确实如此。确实如此。那么，大家好。欢迎回到1974年。日期是3月4日，星期一。这就是我们上次结束的地方，哈罗德·威尔逊在经历了那场动荡之后重新担任首相。谈谈那天报纸上到底写了什么会很有趣。报纸上有什么，能让你对国民生活的风貌有一个大致的了解。如果你仔细阅读报纸的小字部分，
in Norfolk, in Norwich, there is an unofficial strike by railway guards, which means that all the trains are cancelled or delayed. Well, that never happens now. In Lincoln, there have been power cuts because police say that teenage snipers with air rifles have been firing on power lines or whatever. The little scabs. In Worcestershire, a rural vicar has made waves by complaining that state schools are pagan wildernesses, where what he calls a mild kind of sociology has replaced Christian values. Well, he's not wrong.
在诺福克的诺里奇，铁路警卫举行了非官方罢工，这意味着所有的火车都被取消或延误了。嗯，现在这种情况永远不会发生。在林肯，发生了停电，因为警方说十几岁的狙击手用气步枪射击输电线之类的东西。这些小混蛋。在伍斯特郡，一位乡村牧师因为抱怨公立学校是异教徒的荒野而引起了轰动，在那里，他所说的某种温和的社会学取代了基督教价值观。嗯，他没说错。
In Oxford, there has been fighting between different students, student groups, obviously very militant in the 70s, outside the university administration offices, and police have had to separate them. So Tory students and more left-wing students. Tory students. I mean, that is something you don't get nowadays. Absolutely. Well, a lot of students were conservatives in the 1970s, in leeds two irish republicans have been jailed for possessing
在牛津，不同的学生团体之间发生了冲突，显然在70年代非常激进，就在大学行政办公室外，警察不得不把他们分开。所以是保守党学生和更左翼的学生。保守党学生。我的意思是，那是你现在看不到的东西。绝对是。嗯，很多学生在70年代是保守派。在利兹，两名爱尔兰共和党人因持有
more than 60 detonators and 700 rounds of ammunition and that's a story that will obviously run through this podcast now there are a couple of sporting stories for you tom so one of them is a cricket story the england cricket team have just lost in barbados by 10 wickets so that's a lot yes for people who know nothing about cricket that's a very bad result and uh one sports reporter wrote i have never known a more chilling moment on tour the home truth is inescapable batting wise this england party is the weakest ever sent overseas limited in skill character character and guts. And so often sports is taken as a kind of barometer of the nation's wider fortunes.
超过60个雷管和700发弹药而被监禁，这是一个显然会贯穿本期播客的故事。现在有几个体育新闻要告诉你，汤姆。其中一个是板球新闻，英格兰板球队刚刚在巴巴多斯以10个三柱门的优势输掉了比赛，所以那是一个很大的差距。是的，对于那些对板球一无所知的人来说，这是一个非常糟糕的结果。而且，一位体育记者写道：我从未在巡回赛中经历过比这更令人心寒的时刻。残酷的事实是不可避免的，在击球方面，这支英格兰队是史上最弱的海外远征队，在技巧、性格和胆量上都很有限。体育经常被视为国家更广泛命运的一种晴雨表。
And this is also the case in football. Now, this is a great moment, a very important moment in world history, because Wolverhampton Wanderers this weekend have won the League Cup, Tom, at Wembley. Well done, Dominic. Well done. And they have beaten Manchester City. And Manchester City's star striker, Rodney Marsh, who's one of the few footballers whose name would have been known to lots of people in the 1970s. Although, confusingly, the same name as the Australian wicketkeeper.
足球也是如此。现在，这是一个伟大的时刻，世界历史上一个非常重要的时刻，因为狼队（Wolverhampton Wanderers）这个周末在温布利赢得了联赛杯，汤姆。干得好，多米尼克。干得好。他们击败了曼城。曼城的明星前锋罗德尼·马什，他是少数几个名字在1970年代被许多人所熟知的足球运动员之一。尽管令人困惑的是，他和澳大利亚板球守门员同名。
I mean, most people in England would never have heard of this fellow. He's got a massive walrus moustache. So Rodney Marsh, who was sort of very much a Jack the Lad, he had stormed off at the final whistle and he hadn't waited to collect his silver tankard from the Duchess of Kent. And the Daily Mirror, which was the best-selling paper in the country
我的意思是，英格兰的大多数人可能从未听说过这家伙。他留着巨大的海象胡子。所以罗德尼·马什，他是一个非常典型的“花花公子”，他在终场哨响时愤然离场，没有等待从肯特公爵夫人手中领取他的银制酒杯。而《每日镜报》，那是当时全国最畅销的报纸，
in the early 1970s, said, they doubted if he will ever be totally forgiven for his sour, rancid attitude and his appalling lack of sportsmanship. Marsh spat on a tradition that in this country, the loser is expected to summon up a smile and not run away at the end to sulk and scowl alone. So Manchester City, popular as ever. Well, there is a lesson there as well, Tom, for the politician we were talking about last time, Ted Heath, because he is just about to
在1970年代早期，他们说，他们怀疑他是否会因为他那酸溜溜、令人厌恶的态度和极其缺乏体育精神而得到完全的原谅。马什践踏了一个传统，即在这个国家，失败者被期望能挤出一丝微笑，而不是在最后跑开去独自生闷气和皱眉头。所以曼城，一如既往地受欢迎。嗯，那里也有一个教训，汤姆，对于我们上次谈到的那位政治家，泰德·希思，因为他正要
embark on the biggest sulk in history. Yes. He loves the sulk, doesn't he? The incredible sulk, he was called. He was indeed. So just to recap, the end of the last episode, Ted Heath failed in his attempt to have coalition talks with Jeremy Thorpe. In came Harold Wilson. So as we said before, he's the son of an industrial chemist from West Yorkshire. He was a brilliant prodigy, great mind, statistician, economist. He enjoys Agatha Christie, Gilbert and Sullivan. He has a very kind of, I suppose, in a very low key way, a kind of populist style, doesn't he, Tom? You have a wonderful description of him in Seasons of the Sun, your wonderful book about this, where you describe him as a quick-witted, kind-hearted, unpretentious little man. Yeah. It's a bit of a self-portrait,
开始历史上最大的生闷气。是的。他喜欢生闷气，不是吗？他被称为“不可思议的闷气王”。他确实是。所以简单回顾一下，上一集的结尾，泰德·希思试图与杰里米·索普进行联合政府谈判失败了。哈罗德·威尔逊上台了。正如我们之前所说，他是西约克郡一位工业化学家的儿子。他是一位天才神童，头脑敏锐，统计学家，经济学家。他喜欢阿加莎·克里斯蒂，喜欢吉尔伯特和萨利文。他有一种，我想，以一种非常低调的方式，一种民粹主义的风格，不是吗，汤姆？你在你的精彩著作《太阳的季节》（Seasons of the Sun）中对他有很棒的描述，你形容他是一个机智、善良、不装腔作势的小个子男人。是的。这有点像自画像，
to be honest with you, Tom. I was wondering about that. That is high praise in Sandbrook terms. Unpretentious is the ultimate word of approbation. Anyway, so Wilson has come back in. He's very tired. He's shop-soiled. He didn't expect to come in. He's got the most horrendous challenge, arguably one of the worst inheritances of any prime minister in modern British history. The miners are out on strike, if you remember from last time. Britain is still on a three-day week, and it's facing this colossal financial and economic crisis with a record trade deficit. They cared a lot about trade deficits in those days because that affected confidence in the pound. The Bank of England has
老实说，汤姆。我一直在想这个问题。以桑德布鲁克的标准来看，这可是极高的赞誉。不装腔作势是赞许的终极词汇。总之，威尔逊回来了。他非常疲惫。他已经“陈旧”了。他没料到会回来。他面临着最可怕的挑战，可以说是现代英国历史上任何首相所面临的最糟糕的遗产之一。矿工们正在罢工，如果你还记得上次的话。英国仍然处于每周工作三天的状态，并且正面临着巨大的金融和经济危机，贸易逆差创下历史新高。他们在那个年代非常关心贸易逆差，因为那会影响对英镑的信心。英格兰银行刚刚
just raised interest rates to their highest rate in recent memory, 13%. The so-called secondary banks, the smaller banks are in meltdown. The stock market has lost a quarter of its value in just a month. So share price is collapsing. So this is a horrendous, horrendous challenge for anybody. And the thing is that Wilson, in 1964, when he'd first come in, he was the sort of the incarnation of kind of optimism and energy. And this time, he's not at all. He is knackered.
将利率提高到了近期记忆中的最高水平，13%。所谓的二级银行，即较小的银行，正处于崩溃之中。股市在一个月内损失了四分之一的价值。所以股价正在崩盘。这对任何人来说都是一个极其可怕的挑战。问题在于，威尔逊在1964年第一次上台时，他是那种乐观和活力的化身。而这一次，他完全不是。他精疲力竭。
He keeps telling his advisors that he suffers from something that he describes as the squitters. Yeah, too much detail. He has all these eye infections. He just seems constantly ill. And the other thing is, it is very clear from his AIDS memoirs and diaries that he is drinking a lot. And he had been drinking during the election campaign. So Bernard Donoghue, who I'll mention quite a lot today and in the next
他一直告诉他的顾问，他患有一种他称之为“腹泻”的病。是的，细节太多了。他有各种眼部感染。他似乎总是生病。另一件事是，从他的助手们的回忆录和日记中可以非常清楚地看出，他在大量饮酒。他在竞选期间一直在喝酒。所以伯纳德·多诺霍，我今天和下一集会经常提到他，
episode, because he was Wilson's policy chief, who wrote a really fascinating, brilliant, colourful diary. If you go through the Donoghue diary again and again, he mentions Wilson drinking. When he drinks, says Donoghue, he becomes very strange and aggressive. His brow lowers and a very strange look comes into his eyes, hunched and brooding. So he will say, you know, today before prime minister's questions in the commons, Harold drank four brandies. He had two more afterwards. 30th of October, he drank five brandies before prime minister's questions. 27th of November, Joe said he was all over the place. He drank too much at this lunch. And then he goes into the house of commons, gives a terrible performance. So this is coming up again and again.
因为他是威尔逊的政策主管，他写了一本非常迷人、精彩、生动的日记。如果你反复阅读多诺霍的日记，他多次提到威尔逊饮酒。多诺霍说，当他喝酒时，他变得非常奇怪和具有攻击性。他的眉头低垂，眼神中出现一种非常奇怪的神情，弓着背，阴沉着脸。所以他会说，你知道，今天在下议院首相问答环节之前，哈罗德喝了四杯白兰地。之后他又喝了两杯。10月30日，他在首相问答环节前喝了五杯白兰地。11月27日，乔说他状态全无。他在午餐时喝得太多了。然后他走进下议院，表现得一塌糊涂。所以这种情况一再出现。
So again, you in your book quote a treasury minister called Edmund Dell. Yes. Who thought that his colleagues were like the characters in Jane Austen's novel, sipping tea and fluttering their eyelashes while the Napoleonic Wars raged across the channel. But actually it's worse than that because they're not sipping tea. No, they're not. They're sipping brandy and whiskey. Well, I suppose the 70s is the sort of high point, isn't it?
所以，你在书中引用了一位财政部大臣埃德蒙·戴尔的话。是的。他认为他的同事们就像简·奥斯汀小说里的人物，一边啜饮茶水，一边扇动睫毛，而拿破仑战争却在海峡对岸肆虐。但实际上情况更糟，因为他们不是在啜饮茶水。不，他们不是。他们是在啜饮白兰地和威士忌。嗯，我想70年代是那种巅峰时期，不是吗？
The liquid lunch. Yeah. And there are all these, you know, if you read journalists' accounts, they will go for lunch with a cabinet minister and the minister would, you know, they'd happily drink a bottle of wine and a couple of snifters afterwards. And then go off and phone the IMF. Yeah, just to ease themselves into the afternoon. So I think British politics in the mid-70s feels like a very dandruff-flecked, tired, cynical, and frankly, alcohol-soaked environment.
液体午餐。是的。而且有所有这些，你知道，如果你读记者的叙述，他们会和内阁大臣一起吃午餐，大臣会，你知道，他们会愉快地喝掉一瓶葡萄酒，然后再喝几杯烈酒。然后去给国际货币基金组织打电话。是的，只是为了让自己轻松进入下午的工作。所以我认为70年代中期的英国政治感觉像是一个充满头皮屑、疲惫、愤世嫉俗，而且坦率地说，被酒精浸透的环境。
But what's also going on in number 10 under Wilson is this much more sort of Baroque soap opera. So to give you a sense of this, on the first full day, he has lunch with his aides, Harold Wilson, number 10, and it's all fine. He's very pleased because it's English food. Wilson is a bit of a nationalist when it comes to food. He doesn't approve of French cheese, for example. Then the second day, day two, they go to lunch and it's all recorded in Bernard Donoghue's diary. He says, terrible lunch. We'll go upstairs to the small dining room. We discussed the central policy review staff and appointment. Suddenly Marcia blows up, already upset because we were eating whitebait. She says she hates them looking at her from the
但在威尔逊领导下的唐宁街10号，还上演着这种更像巴洛克式肥皂剧的戏码。为了让你了解这一点，在第一个完整的工作日，他和他的助手们在唐宁街10号吃午餐，一切都很好。他很高兴，因为那是英式食物。威尔逊在食物方面有点民族主义。例如，他不赞成法国奶酪。然后第二天，第二天，他们去吃午餐，这一切都记录在伯纳德·多诺霍的日记里。他说，糟糕的午餐。我们上楼去小餐厅。我们讨论了中央政策审查小组和任命问题。突然玛西娅爆发了，因为我们吃的是银鱼，她已经很不高兴了。她说她讨厌它们从
plate. The PM solemnly announced that they were from the home for blind whitebait, so she need not worry. That broke the tension for a while, but then she blew up over Harold and me having a polite and friendly conversation together. She said it was disgraceful. She stalked out. H.W., that's Harold Wilson, the prime minister, followed his meal unfinished. Gloom. So Dominic, Marcia. Yes.
盘子里盯着她看。首相庄严地宣布，它们来自“盲银鱼之家”，所以她不必担心。这暂时缓解了紧张气氛，但随后她因为哈罗德和我进行了一次礼貌友好的交谈而爆发了。她说这太可耻了。她愤然离去。H.W.，也就是哈罗德·威尔逊，首相，跟着她离开了，饭还没吃完。阴郁。所以多米尼克，玛西娅。是的。
Who is Marcia? So Marcia Williams is the daughter of a Northamptonshire builder who had started working for the Labour Party in the 1950s. She'd been introduced to Harold Wilson and they'd become very close. And she basically became his private secretary, his absolutely indispensable right hand. She's the guardian of access to Wilson. She does his paperwork. She is, I mean, effectively- Well, she is his political wife. She is his political wife.
玛西娅是谁？玛西娅·威廉姆斯是一位北安普敦郡建筑商的女儿，她在1950年代开始为工党工作。她被介绍给了哈罗德·威尔逊，他们变得非常亲密。她基本上成了他的私人秘书，他绝对不可或缺的得力助手。她是威尔逊接触权的守护者。她处理他的文书工作。她，我的意思是，实际上——嗯，她是他的“政治妻子”。她是他的政治妻子。
So this is the woman that we talked about at the start of the show. Right. So Mary Wilson hated politics, thought that her husband was going to be an Oxford economics don, and was gutted that he actually went into politics in the first place and made it very clear that she was never really going to take any interest in it or do anything but the bare minimum. So Wilson, from the 50s onwards, has had almost like this sort of second wife. So they travel as a trio. Marcia is always there in the background. She is the person who sits up late with him at night. Right. And so, I mean, just to be clear what that means, again, to quote you, Wilson himself once claimed that after a particularly blazing row, Marcia had gone to see his wife, Mary, and announced, I have only one thing to say to you. I went to bed with your husband six times in 1956 and it wasn't satisfactory.
所以这就是我们在节目开始时谈到的那个女人。没错。所以玛丽·威尔逊讨厌政治，认为她的丈夫会成为牛津大学的经济学教授，并且对他在第一时间进入政界并取得成功感到非常失望，她非常明确地表示，她永远不会真正对政治产生兴趣，也不会做任何超出最低限度的事情。所以威尔逊从50年代开始，几乎就像有了第二个妻子。所以他们三人行。玛西娅总是出现在背景中。她是那个晚上陪他熬夜的人。没错。所以，我的意思是，为了弄清楚这意味着什么，再次引用你的话，威尔逊本人曾经声称，在一次特别激烈的争吵后，玛西娅去见了她的妻子玛丽，并宣布：“我只有一件事要对你说。我在1956年和你丈夫睡过六次，而且并不令人满意。”
Well, yes. Quite an odd relationship. Yeah, very odd relationship. She would also say to the other aides, when they were having a big row, she would hold up her handbag and tap her handbag meaningfully. And she would say, one call to the Daily Mail and he'll be finished. I will destroy him. But she never says what the information is. No, what's in the handbag? Tom, what's in the handbag?
嗯，是的。相当奇怪的关系。是的，非常奇怪的关系。当他们发生大争吵时，她还会对其他助手说，她会举起她的手提包，意味深长地拍拍它。她会说：“只要给《每日邮报》打一个电话，他就完了。我会毁了他。”但她从不说那信息是什么。不，手提包里有什么？汤姆，手提包里有什么？
No one ever knows. And the thing about did they have a physical relationship? I think there is a sense that possibly they did. I mean, this is pure gossip and prurience to speculate whether they did or not, because it doesn't really matter. What matters is the intensity of the emotional relationship, which is undeniable. But there's something kind of slightly dominatrix about her, isn't there? I mean, again, reading you. Yeah.
没人知道。关于他们是否有过身体关系？我认为有一种感觉是他们可能确实有过。我的意思是，猜测他们是否有过关系纯粹是八卦和窥私，因为这并不重要。重要的是情感关系的强度，这是不可否认的。但她身上有一种稍微有点“女王”的感觉，不是吗？我的意思是，再次读你的书。是的。
She demands submission and obedience from Wilson. She does. Now, especially to our listeners who are not British or who are younger and don't remember this period at all and have no knowledge of it, all this will sound very weird, but to give you a sort of sense. So we talked about day two and the white bait bust up. On day three, there was another massive row at lunch in number 10 Downing Street. At the end of the meal, Marcia walks out in a temper. HW was clearly upset. She had attacked him viciously in front of the waiter. And then she goes straight home, and Donoghue, the policy guy, has to ring her up past midnight and beg her to come back.
她要求威尔逊服从和顺从。她确实如此。现在，特别是对于我们那些不是英国人或者更年轻、根本不记得这段时期且对此一无所知的听众来说，这一切听起来会非常奇怪，但为了让你有个概念。所以我们谈到了第二天和银鱼争吵事件。第三天，在唐宁街10号的午餐时又发生了另一次大争吵。饭后，玛西娅愤怒地走了出去。H.W.显然很不安。她在服务员面前恶毒地攻击了他。然后她直接回家了，政策主管多诺霍不得不在午夜过后给她打电话，恳求她回来。
She's very depressed and neurotic. She says, we're all out for ourselves. We're ganging up against her, and I'm out to replace her. She says she'll retire to her country home and wait for HW to sack us all, and then he'll have to come personally to ask a return. Now, this may sound madly histrionic, but I can't exaggerate how much time in any given day Harold Wilson and his chief advisors are spending on this issue. I mean, it comes up again and again. And so, Dominic, what solution do Wilson's advisors come up with to this problem that Marseille is basically dominating all their concerns in the midst of Britain's worst post-war crisis? Well, unbelievably, Tom, the opening weeks,
她非常沮丧和神经质。她说，我们都是为了自己。我们都在联合起来对付她，而我正试图取代她。她说她要退休回乡下，等着H.W.把我们都解雇，然后他必须亲自去求她回来。现在，这听起来可能非常戏剧化，但我无法夸大哈罗德·威尔逊和他的首席顾问们在任何一天里花在这个问题上的时间。我的意思是，它一再出现。所以，多米尼克，威尔逊的顾问们想出了什么解决方案来解决玛西娅基本上主导了他们所有担忧的问题，而此时正值英国最严重的战后危机？嗯，令人难以置信的是，汤姆，最初的几周，
so when they've returned in March 1974, much of their time in the opening weeks is spent on very serious top-level negotiations about who will be allowed to have lunch. And the agreement is finally reached. She basically says, Wilson must eat lunch on his own. He is not allowed to eat lunch with his aides. She goes mad if she finds out they've eaten lunch with him. There's a wonderful description in Donoghue's diary. Harold was pleading for food, for sandwiches, but Marcy insisted that he sign her letters before he got his sandwiches. But there is worse.
也就是当他们在1974年3月回来时，最初几周的大部分时间都花在了关于谁被允许吃午餐的非常严肃的顶级谈判上。最终达成了协议。她基本上说，威尔逊必须独自吃午餐。他不被允许和他的助手们一起吃午餐。如果她发现他们和他一起吃午餐，她就会发疯。多诺霍的日记里有一段精彩的描述。哈罗德在乞求食物，乞求三明治，但玛西娅坚持要他在拿到三明治之前签署她的信件。但还有更糟的。
There is far worse. It is mind-boggling. If you think Boris Johnson was the first prime minister to run a ludicrous and chaotic ship in Downing Street, you'll be very surprised by this. So first of all, they've obviously won the election unexpectedly. And they decide they're going to have a victory party at number 10. Now, Bernard Donoghue was a lecturer at the London School of Economics. So he has to go back to give one last lecture before he can kind of come in, in a sort of Henry Kissinger style way. He's come from academia to politics. So he goes off to give a last lecture, thinking the party's this evening at 8.30. And he and his
还有更糟的。这简直令人难以置信。如果你认为鲍里斯·约翰逊是第一个在唐宁街经营一艘荒谬而混乱的船的首相，你会对这个感到非常惊讶。首先，他们显然出人意料地赢得了选举。他们决定在10号举行庆祝派对。现在，伯纳德·多诺霍是伦敦政治经济学院的讲师。所以他必须回去做最后一次讲座，然后才能以一种亨利·基辛格的方式进入政界。他从学术界转向了政界。所以他去做了最后一次讲座，以为派对是今晚8点半。他和他的
wife, Carol, turn up at 8.30 at number 10 Downing Street. But actually behind his back that afternoon, Marcia has canceled the party in a rage. So when he and his wife arrive, they're the only people there. And Wilson greets them, very sheepish and shamefaced, and actually says to them, Oh, hello. He says, it's all a pantomime. It's a riot, quite chaotic. Nobody outside would believe it.
妻子卡罗尔在8点半出现在唐宁街10号。但实际上那天下午在他背后，玛西娅愤怒地取消了派对。所以当他和他的妻子到达时，他们是那里唯一的人。威尔逊迎接他们，非常羞怯和尴尬，实际上对他们说：“哦，你好。”他说：“这简直是一场闹剧。这简直是一场骚乱，非常混乱。外面没人会相信。”
A total pantomime. I mean, for him to say this about his own administration. Yeah. Well, at least he's self-aware. And he has a drink with them. And Marcia brings up half-fifth of the evening and gives him a 40 minute rollicking on the phone. For having a drink? For having a drink with Donoghue. And is this kind of jealousy of his aides? Yes. Jealousy of the other aides. But of course, the most eye-catching story, Tom. Yes. So this will have to be bleeped out.
一场彻底的闹剧。我的意思是，他竟然这样评价自己的政府。嗯，至少他有自知之明。他和他们喝了一杯。玛西娅在晚上晚些时候出现，在电话里对他进行了40分钟的训斥。因为喝了一杯？因为和多诺霍喝了一杯。这种对助手的嫉妒是这样吗？是的。嫉妒其他助手。但当然，最引人注目的故事，汤姆。是的。所以这必须被消音。
So we're in the middle of the economic crisis, and she tells Harold Wilson that she wants him to come with her to a reception at the House of Lords. He goes to the reception. This is the Prime Minister of the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern Ireland. But he and his speechwriter, Jo Haynes, sneak off from the reception to get back to Number 10 Downing Street to do some work. She comes back to Number 10 because she's spotted that he's missing from the reception.
所以我们正处于经济危机之中，她告诉哈罗德·威尔逊，她要他陪她去上议院参加一个招待会。他去了招待会。这是大不列颠及北爱尔兰联合王国的首相。但他和他的演讲稿撰写人乔·海恩斯从招待会上溜走，回到唐宁街10号工作。她回到10号，因为她发现他从招待会上消失了。
And in full view of everybody there, the staff, she shouts at him, you little, what do you think you're doing? You come back with me at once. And did he go back with her? And he went back. Yeah. That does seem quite a kind of psycho sexual dominatrix kind of thing going on there. So Joe Haynes, who is his speechwriter, who was a very kind of hard-bitten man, a former newspaper man, he wrote in his memoirs about this and he said, you know, I was frankly very shocked at this, that you could speak to the Prime
在所有在场的人，包括工作人员面前，她对他大喊：“你这个小东西，你以为你在做什么？你马上跟我回去。”他跟她回去了吗？他回去了。是的。这看起来确实有一种相当心理性、女王式的支配感。所以乔·海恩斯，他的演讲稿撰写人，一个非常坚强的人，前报社记者，他在回忆录中写到了这件事，他说：“我坦率地说对此感到非常震惊，你竟然可以在所有人面前这样对首相说话。”
Minister like this in front of everybody. Yeah, well, it is shocking. I mean, it's frankly very odd. It is very odd. I mean, it's inconceivable that somebody would have spoken like this to Ted Heath. Okay. So all this psychodrama is going on in number 10 and monopolizing Wilson's attention. But meanwhile, there is a country in crisis to run. So how are things getting on out on the streets, out in the country? Well, you will remember that the miners are out on strike. So the first thing that Harold Wilson does when he comes back is he settles with the miners.
是的，这确实令人震惊。我的意思是，这坦率地说非常奇怪。这非常奇怪。我的意思是，不可想象有人会这样对泰德·希思说话。好吧。所有这些心理剧都在10号上演，并垄断了威尔逊的注意力。但与此同时，还有一个处于危机的国家需要治理。那么街头、全国的情况如何呢？嗯，你会记得矿工们正在罢工。所以哈罗德·威尔逊回来后做的第一件事就是与矿工达成协议。
So within days, the guy who's got to take charge of industrial relations, who our British listeners will recognize the name, Michael Foote, a sort of pamphleteer, radical pamphleteer, a journalist. Great enthusiast for Byron. Great enthusiast for Byron, a very erudite man, but not really one of life's natural administrators. He's been put in because the unions know he'll basically give them what they want. And he does. He gave the miners a wage settlement. You will remember, it asked for 35%. Foot gave them 32% wage settlement worth 108 million pounds. So that's double what Ted Heath was offering them. He basically bribes them to go back to work if you were being harsh. Now, what the Labour Party have done is they have
所以几天之内，那个必须负责劳资关系的人，我们的英国听众会认出这个名字，迈克尔·富特，一个所谓的政论家，激进的政论家，一名记者。拜伦的狂热爱好者。拜伦的狂热爱好者，一个非常有学问的人，但并不是那种天生的行政管理者。他被安排进来是因为工会知道他基本上会给他们想要的。他确实给了。他给了矿工一份工资协议。你会记得，他们要求35%。富特给了他们32%的工资协议，价值1.08亿英镑。所以那是泰德·希思提供给他们的两倍。如果你说得刻薄一点，他基本上是贿赂他们回去工作。现在，工党所做的是他们
a policy called the social contract. So fans of Jean-Jacques Rousseau will enjoy this policy. What this involves is they say, listen, we will give the unions all kinds of goodies. So you'll get improved health and safety. You'll get anti-discrimination laws. You will get better pensions. You will get better sick pay. And the quid pro quo is that if we give you all these treats, you will not keep asking for more money. It's a contract, effectively. And is this a legally enforceable contract? No. No. It depends on the unions doing their bit. And also, as we described before, there are hundreds of trade unions. They're very competitive with each other. They're always trying to outbid each other. So actually, the people who run the union movement or sort of preside over it, so Len Murray, who's the head of the Trade Union Congress, he had said to Wilson, you know, deep down, actually, we won't really be able to deliver on our side of this bargain. Joe Gormley, the leader of the miners, had said to him, don't put us in a false position.
有一项政策叫“社会契约”。所以让-雅克·卢梭的粉丝会喜欢这个政策。这涉及的内容是，他们说：“听着，我们会给工会各种各样的好处。你们会得到改善的健康和安全。你们会得到反歧视法。你们会得到更好的养老金。你们会得到更好的病假工资。”而交换条件是，如果我们给你们所有这些款待，你们就不会一直要求更多的钱。这实际上是一份契约。这是一份具有法律约束力的契约吗？不。不。这取决于工会是否履行他们的职责。而且，正如我们之前描述的那样，有数百个工会。他们之间竞争非常激烈。他们总是试图互相竞价。所以实际上，那些经营工会运动或主持它的人，比如莱恩·默里，他是工会大会的负责人，他曾对威尔逊说：“你知道，在内心深处，实际上，我们真的无法履行我们在这笔交易中的那部分。”矿工领袖乔·戈姆利曾对他说：“不要把我们置于虚假的境地。”
And I quote, our role in society is to look after our members, not to run the country. But the social contract was good politics. It made it sound like they had a solution to the problem of high inflation. But also Michael Foot is an incredible romantic, isn't he? Yeah. So he really believes it. Yes. Oh, Michael Foot, like a lot of people at that time, he had two things. One was, I would argue, they completely misunderstood the ability of the trade union leaders and willingness of the trade union leaders to deliver on promises to government. They ignored the union leaders when the union leaders said, don't ask of us something we can't deliver. But secondly, they have this incredibly rose-tinted romantic idea of trade unions and all of this kind of thing, which actually people who are closer to the union movement often say, you're being very starry-eyed and silly about this. They are hard-nosed negotiators. They will ask for the best deal possible. Doesn't one of the trade union leaders compare the government to a slot machine in Vegas where they're just pouring money out all the time?
我引用一下：“我们在社会中的角色是照顾我们的成员，而不是治理国家。”但社会契约是很好的政治。它让人们觉得他们有解决高通胀问题的办法。而且迈克尔·富特是一个不可思议的浪漫主义者，不是吗？是的。所以他真的相信它。是的。哦，迈克尔·富特，像当时很多人一样，他有两件事。一是，我认为，他们完全误解了工会领袖的能力以及工会领袖履行对政府承诺的意愿。当工会领袖说“不要要求我们做我们无法交付的事情”时，他们忽视了工会领袖。但其次，他们对工会和所有这类事情有一种极其玫瑰色的浪漫想法，而实际上那些更接近工会运动的人经常说：“你们对这件事太天真、太愚蠢了。他们是强硬的谈判者。他们会要求最好的交易。”难道没有一个工会领袖把政府比作拉斯维加斯的角子机，他们一直在往外倒钱吗？
Yeah. The postman's leader, Tom Jackson. The postman's leader, yeah. A gigantic Las Vegas slot machine that got stuck in favor of the customer. Well, because actually, if you look at what they gave them, the power workers got a 31% deal. The civil servants got 32%. The doctors, 35%. The dockers, 30%. So wages go up by about a third in the course of 1974. And the weird thing is that each time a given trade union leader would go into number 10, have his beer and sandwiches, actually smoked salmon and white wine, and then he'd come out with this massive pay settlement for his members. He would say on the way out often to the government, you can't keep doing this. I mean, this is mad. You can't keep giving me all this money.
是的。邮递员领袖汤姆·杰克逊。邮递员领袖，是的。一个巨大的拉斯维加斯角子机，卡在了有利于顾客的位置。嗯，因为实际上，如果你看看他们给了他们什么，电力工人得到了31%的协议。公务员得到了32%。医生，35%。码头工人，30%。所以工资在1974年期间上涨了大约三分之一。奇怪的是，每次某个工会领袖走进10号，喝了他的啤酒和三明治，实际上是烟熏三文鱼和白葡萄酒，然后他带着为他的成员争取到的巨额加薪走出来。他经常在离开时对政府说：“你们不能一直这样做。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。你们不能一直给我这么多钱。”
But in private, of course. Yeah. Right. And because the oil crisis is ongoing, a bit like we've been going through with Ukraine, there's this massive spike. So inflation is going up everywhere across the world, but is it now starting to go up much further in Britain than anywhere else? Yes, this is the thing. Every Western European country is facing similar problems. Indeed, every developed country because of the massive spike in oil prices. However, within about a year of the Wilson government coming in, as a result of these pay settlements, prices are going up faster in Great Britain than they are in any other european
但在私下里，当然。是的。没错。而且因为石油危机正在持续，有点像我们经历的乌克兰危机，有一个巨大的飙升。所以通货膨胀在世界各地都在上升，但它现在是否开始在英国比在其他任何地方上升得更多？是的，这就是问题所在。每个西欧国家都面临着类似的问题。事实上，每个发达国家都因为石油价格的巨大飙升而面临同样的问题。然而，在威尔逊政府上台大约一年后，由于这些工资协议，英国的价格上涨速度比其他任何欧洲
country by a margin of about five times tom five times five times faster in britain than anywhere else god and as a result of this because the money is pouring into the economy the prices of goods are going up as well so sugar 184 percent vegetables 137%. Even little things, sort of tin soup, the price goes up by 54%. Orange squash, 51%. So this is cost of living crisis on steroids. On steroids. So worse than the one that we've been going through over the past few years, do you think? That's a good question.
国家都要快，幅度大约是五倍，汤姆。五倍。英国的价格上涨速度比其他任何地方快五倍。天哪。结果，因为钱涌入经济，商品价格也在上涨。所以糖上涨了184%，蔬菜上涨了137%。即使是小东西，比如罐装汤，价格也上涨了54%。橙汁饮料，51%。所以这是类固醇驱动的生活成本危机。类固醇驱动的。所以比我们过去几年经历的那场更糟，你觉得吗？这是一个好问题。
I would say it depends who you are, right? So if you are the power worker who's just got a 35% pay rise. It's brilliant. Well, it's not brilliant, actually. But you're keeping your head above water. You're keeping your head above water is what it is. Yeah. If you're not represented by a trade union, or you're a pensioner on a fixed pension,
我会说这取决于你是谁，对吧？所以如果你是刚刚获得35%加薪的电力工人。这很棒。嗯，实际上并不棒。但你维持了生计。维持生计就是这样。是的。如果你没有工会代表，或者你是一个拿着固定养老金的退休人员，
or you're a student, or you're poor, this is unbelievably painful because nobody is getting you a pay rise, or if your union is weak and doesn't have any clout with the government. So it's at this point that you see a real kind of fracturing, a fraying of, well, I suppose you would say kind of class solidarity or a kind of a sense of national solidarity because inflation is dividing people into winners and losers. But also, Dominic, just to say that at this point, class consciousness is really, really important, isn't it? Much more important than it is now, in the 1970s, certainly people on the left will use the language of class much more quickly and automatically than they would today. And there was much more a sense of the great conflict in British society being one between classes, whereas I think now, Tom, it's between the
或者你是一个学生，或者你很穷，这令人难以置信地痛苦，因为没有人给你加薪，或者如果你的工会很弱，对政府没有任何影响力。所以正是在这一点上，你看到了某种真正的分裂，某种“阶级团结”的磨损，或者某种国家团结感的磨损，因为通货膨胀正在把人们分成赢家和输家。但多米尼克，也要说的是，在这一点上，阶级意识真的非常非常重要，不是吗？比现在重要得多，在1970年代，当然，左派人士使用阶级语言的速度比今天快得多，也更自动。而且英国社会中存在着一种更大的冲突感，即阶级之间的冲突，而我认为现在，汤姆，是
populists and the elite. People didn't really talk that way in the 70s. They much more talked about the bosses and the working man, people in top hats and people in cloth caps. People still use that quite dated language of class. I guess people on the left today might be ready to talk about race or sexual identity or whatever than class, but those are not issues that are seen as being salient to the same degree back in the 70s. Would that be fair? I think that's absolutely right. That's absolutely right. So to give you a sense, just before we go to the break, of what else is going on, Wilson's chancellor is a guy called Dennis Healy. We talked about him last time. He'd been in the landings at Anzio.
民粹主义者和精英之间的冲突。人们在70年代并不真的那样说话。他们更多地谈论老板和工人，戴高帽的人和戴布帽的人。人们仍然使用那种相当过时的阶级语言。我想今天的左派人士可能比阶级更愿意谈论种族或性身份之类的东西，但这些并不是在70年代被视为具有同样显著性的问题。这样说公平吗？我认为这绝对正确。这绝对正确。所以为了让你在休息前了解一下还有什么正在发生，威尔逊的财政大臣是一个叫丹尼斯·希利的家伙。我们上次谈到过他。他曾在安齐奥登陆。
Big eyebrows. Loves quoting Yeats. Always quoting Yeats and talking about Russian literature. He comes in. Healy is, in many ways, a very cynical politician. He says, we're facing a massive economic crisis. On the other hand, we've got a tiny majority and there's going to be another election quite soon. So actually, we'll just- Yeah, chuck money at the problem. Throw money around. Throw fuel on the fire. So massive new spending on things like pensions and food subsidies and things like this. And
大眉毛。喜欢引用叶芝。总是引用叶芝并谈论俄罗斯文学。他进来了。希利在许多方面是一个非常愤世嫉俗的政治家。他说：“我们正面临巨大的经济危机。另一方面，我们只有微小的多数，很快就会有另一次选举。所以实际上，我们只是——是的，把钱扔给问题。”到处扔钱。火上浇油。所以对养老金和食品补贴等事情进行了大规模的新支出。而且
that's going to be paid for by taxes on the rich. So we were talking about the pips squeaking. So just to give you a sense of what those taxes are, the higher rate of income tax, Tom, as a representative of the rich yourself, I think you'll find this very painful. The higher rate of income tax was raised to 83%. And Tom, I don't know if you have investments, but if you did, the tax rate on the higher rates on your investments would be a very impressive 98%. Goodness. So this is when the Rolling Stones are going off to South of France and things, is it? Exactly so. Exactly. But not Paul McCartney. Paul McCartney stays and does his patriotic duty. Oh, that's nice. So Daily Telegraph readers, sort of Middle England, are in absolute and utter meltdown
那将由对富人的税收来支付。所以我们谈到了“小鸡吱吱叫”。为了让你了解那些税收是什么，所得税的最高税率，汤姆，作为富人的代表，我想你会觉得这非常痛苦。所得税的最高税率被提高到了83%。汤姆，我不知道你是否有投资，但如果你有，你投资的最高税率将是一个非常令人印象深刻的98%。天哪。所以这就是滚石乐队去法国南部之类的地方的时候，是吗？正是如此。正是如此。但保罗·麦卡特尼没有。保罗·麦卡特尼留下来履行了他的爱国义务。哦，那很好。《每日电讯报》的读者，也就是中产阶级，正处于绝对和彻底的崩溃中
about this. What's compounding all this is that, remember, some of our more attentive listeners will remember that the Labour Party have come to office with an incredibly radical manifesto. They're going to set up a national enterprise board to spend billions of pounds a year to buy up British companies and to institute massive state planning. And the man in charge of this is Tony Benn, the British Salvador Allende, as he was called at the time. And he came in and his own officials said to him when he arrived, well, surely you don't really mean it. You're not really going to do this, are you? And he said,
关于这一点。让这一切变得更复杂的是，记住，我们一些更细心的听众会记得，工党带着一份极其激进的宣言上台了。他们要建立一个国家企业委员会，每年花费数十亿英镑来收购英国公司并实施大规模的国家计划。负责这件事的人是托尼·本，当时被称为“英国的萨尔瓦多·阿连德”。他进来了，当他到达时，他自己的官员对他说：“嗯，你肯定不是真的意思吧。你不是真的要这样做，对吧？”他说，
oh yeah, I'm very committed to this. And they started leaking against him, his own officials, amusing lists of companies that they thought would be soon for the government takeover. The Daily Express got this list from Ben's own officials. He was going to take over Woman's Own, nationalized Woman's Own magazine, Tom, Cow and Gate baby foods, Beaulieu sausages, baby Sham, the popular drink, Double Diamond, and the gourmet food emporium, Bernie Innes.
“哦，是的，我非常致力于此。”他们开始泄露对他不利的消息，他自己的官员，列出了他们认为很快会被政府接管的有趣的公司名单。 《每日快报》从本自己的官员那里得到了这份名单。他要接管《女性杂志》（Woman's Own），国有化《女性杂志》，汤姆，Cow and Gate婴儿食品，博利厄香肠，Baby Sham，那种流行的饮料，Double Diamond，以及美食食品商场Bernie Innes。
Because Tony Benn is very abstemious, isn't he? Yeah. He likes his tea, but not much else. I wouldn't have him running Harp and Baby Sham and Double Diamond.
因为托尼·本非常节制，不是吗？是的。他喜欢他的茶，但除此之外没别的。我不会让他经营Harp、Baby Sham和Double Diamond。
No. I'm not sure I'd have him running a chain of restaurants. No. I mean, Bernie Innes were terrible as it was. But he could make them worse. Yeah. And actually, he has come in and he really believes that they're going to do this. He's absolutely devoted to this nationalization
不。我不确定我会让他经营一家连锁餐厅。不。我的意思是，Bernie Innes本来就很糟糕。但他可能会让他们变得更糟。是的。而且实际上，他进来了，他真的相信他们会这样做。他绝对致力于这个国有化
plan. And actually, in June 1974, some of Wilson's other ministers, so the barons, the power brokers in the Wilson government, two men, they are Dennis Healy, we mentioned the chancellor, and they are James Callaghan, the Foreign Secretary, who are both on the right of the Labour Party and who are real bruisers. And Healy and Callaghan kind of team up in this period, and they're always going to see Harold Wilson, who's sitting there with his brandy. And they're always saying to him, you know, do this, do that, don't do this, and so on. And they go to see him, and they give him an absolute roasting and say, you have to control Tony Benn. You can't let him do any of this. And I quote,
计划。而且实际上，在1974年6月，威尔逊的其他一些大臣，也就是威尔逊政府中的男爵们、权力掮客们，两个人，他们是丹尼斯·希利，我们提到的财政大臣，以及詹姆斯·卡拉汉，外交大臣，他们都在工党的右翼，而且是真正的“打手”。希利和卡拉汉在这一时期联手了，他们总是去见哈罗德·威尔逊，他正坐在那里喝着白兰地。他们总是对他说：“你知道，做这个，做那个，别做这个，等等。”他们去见他，对他进行了彻底的严厉批评，说：“你必须控制托尼·本。你不能让他做任何这些事情。”我引用一下，
otherwise there will be a total collapse of confidence and no investment. And Wilson just goes around saying to everybody, well, I'm not going to let Benn do anything. He's completely mad. I mean, that is the quote. He is completely mad. And he actually briefs the press to say that he thinks Tony Benn is mad and he's not going to allow him to do anything. So why doesn't he sack him if he And he actually briefs the press to say that he thinks Tony Benn is mad and he's not going to allow him to do anything. So why doesn't he sack him if he thinks he's mad? Because he's weak, Tom. I like Harold Wilson in lots of ways. I've gone on the record of saying I would like to have him as my next door neighbour. I admire his love of scouting and of Gilbert and Sullivan. His taste in shorts. Yes, his nice khaki shorts. However, he is quite a weak leader and he won't sack people but also he's leading a minority government yes so he has no real i mean mary in that poem that you read so
“否则信心将彻底崩溃，没有投资。”而威尔逊只是到处对每个人说：“嗯，我不会让本做任何事情。他完全疯了。”我的意思是，这就是那句话。他完全疯了。而且他实际上向媒体简报说，他认为托尼·本疯了，他不会允许他做任何事情。那么如果他认为他疯了，为什么不解雇他呢？因为他软弱，汤姆。我在很多方面都喜欢哈罗德·威尔逊。我曾公开表示，我希望他成为我的邻居。我钦佩他对童子军和吉尔伯特与萨利文的热爱。他穿短裤的品味。是的，他那条漂亮的卡其色短裤。然而，他是一个相当软弱的领导者，他不会解雇人，而且他领导的是一个少数派政府，是的，所以他没有真正的——我的意思是，玛丽在你读的那首诗里，所以
beautifully she mentioned his tiny mandate i mean he has no mandate he has no mandate at all does he so he's got this minority government they're totally divided the atmosphere inside number 10 is bonkers and they are staggering closer and closer, it seems, to economic disaster. So Dominic, in the previous episode, we talked about how many people in Britain were comparing the country to Weimar Germany, to Allende's Chile, both of which obviously resulted in, one might say, a swing to the right. And there is quite a lot of discussion, isn't there? There is. In gentlemen's clubs and so on about what can be done to solve the problem.
她非常漂亮地提到了他那微不足道的授权，我的意思是，他根本没有任何授权，一点都没有，不是吗？所以他现在领导的是一个少数派政府，他们内部完全分裂，唐宁街10号里的气氛简直疯了，而且他们似乎正摇摇欲坠地一步步走向经济灾难。多米尼克，在上一集中，我们谈到了英国有多少人将这个国家比作魏玛德国或阿连德时期的智利，这两者显然都导致了——有人可能会说——向右转。而且现在确实有很多讨论，不是吗？确实有。在绅士俱乐部等地，人们都在讨论能做些什么来解决这个问题。
Well, the exciting thing, Tom, is that Britain's penichet is waiting in the wings and not just one of them. There are two. So I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, let's look at the plans for a right-wing coup. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
嗯，令人兴奋的是，汤姆，英国的皮诺切特正蓄势待发，而且不止一个。有两个。所以我认为我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们看看右翼政变的计划。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at the Wilson government, the first Wilson government of 1974 and Dominic we've been talking about psychosexual dramas, imploding economy. And we mentioned at the end of the first half of this episode, mutterings in gentlemen's clubs about a right-wing coup. So, I mean, it's this sense of anxiety that kind of retired colonels and so on are feeling. Is this shared across the whole country? Is there a kind of consciousness that everything is going tits up or do most people think actually you know
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告内容、额外剧集并优先获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。我们正在审视威尔逊政府，即1974年的第一届威尔逊政府。多米尼克，我们一直在谈论心理性戏剧和崩溃的经济。我们在本集前半部分结束时提到了绅士俱乐部里关于右翼政变的私语。所以，我的意思是，这种焦虑感是退休上校们等人的感受。这种感受在全国范围内是普遍的吗？是否有一种意识认为一切都在搞砸，还是大多数人认为其实你知道
it's fine space hoppers and rally bikes and yeah all that kind of sandbrook stuff all right is that what that technical term is it yeah because this is your argument that the headlines are saying chaos disaster whatever but meanwhile people are getting on with their lives and enjoying new types of chocolate bar or washing machines or whatever, and they don't really notice. I think there is an interesting divergence here. So if you were paying that 83% rate of tax or 98% on your unearned income, as it was called at the time, if you invest in property or any of these other markets that have collapsed, then you are sitting there and saying, this is Weimar Germany, this is Chile, you know, 1973. The pauperization of the middle classes.
没关系，太空跳跳球、拉力赛自行车，还有所有那些桑德布鲁克式的东西，好吧，这就是那个技术术语吗？是的，因为这是你的论点，头条新闻都在说混乱、灾难等等，但与此同时，人们正在继续他们的生活，享受着新型巧克力棒或洗衣机之类的东西，他们并没有真正注意到。我认为这里有一个有趣的差异。所以，如果你当时正在缴纳83%的税率，或者对所谓的“非劳动收入”缴纳98%的税，如果你投资了房地产或任何其他已经崩溃的市场，那么你就会坐在那里说，这就是魏玛德国，这就是1973年的智利。中产阶级的贫困化。
The pauperization of the middle classes, exactly. You know, the country's going to hell in a hand cart. It's time for the rule of the gun. However, if you're not one of those people, is life terrible? Arguably not, especially if your income has been protected by your union. Don't forget, just under half the country belong to a trade union. And those people, often, they're not doing that badly. So actually, not least because Harold Wilson has sent the miners back to work, the three-day week is over, the state of emergency is over. So I think people feel we've got the calmer, quieter life that we want. Now, interestingly enough, a lot of Wilson's own ministers don't think like that. So they are relatively well off, of course, because they're well paid. Government minister
中产阶级的贫困化，没错。你知道，国家正坐着手推车下地狱。是时候动用枪杆子了。然而，如果你不是那些人中的一员，生活真的很糟糕吗？未必，特别是如果你的收入受到工会的保护。别忘了，全国有不到一半的人属于工会。而这些人，通常情况下，他们过得并不算太差。所以实际上，尤其是因为哈罗德·威尔逊让矿工们复工了，三日工作制结束了，紧急状态也结束了。所以我认为人们觉得我们得到了我们想要的更平静、更安静的生活。现在，有趣的是，威尔逊自己的许多部长并不这么想。当然，他们相对富裕，因为他们薪水很高。政府部长
salary was comparatively much higher in the mid 1970s than it is today. So they're among the better off people in society. They have gone abroad on holiday. And often the people who've gone abroad on holiday come back and they say, oh my God, the contrast is so painful. So Roy Jenkins, who's Wilson's home secretary at this period, he says, I know we're heading for catastrophe. I can't stand by, he says to Barbara Castle, and watch and see us pretend everything is all right. Pretend.
的薪水在70年代中期比今天高得多。所以他们是社会上比较富裕的人群。他们去国外度假。而那些去国外度假的人回来后经常说，天哪，这种对比太痛苦了。所以罗伊·詹金斯，也就是这一时期威尔逊的内政大臣，他说，我知道我们正在走向灾难。他对芭芭拉·卡素尔说，我不能袖手旁观，看着我们假装一切都好。假装。
He would say pretend. Very good, Tom. Very good. That's the kind of forensic is all right. Pretend. He would say pretend. Very good, Tom. Very good. That's the kind of forensic- Attention to detail. Detail, yeah, that marks out the truly great historian, I think. And Donoghue, Bernard Donoghue, who is this former LSE academic, who was Wilson's head of the policy unit in number 10,
他会说假装。非常好，汤姆。非常好。这就是那种法医般的——注意细节。细节，是的，我认为这标志着一位真正伟大的历史学家。还有多诺霍，伯纳德·多诺霍，他是前伦敦政治经济学院的学者，曾任唐宁街10号威尔逊政策部门的负责人，
he writes in his diary himself, he's gone off for a month's holiday in France. The month's holiday in France that the head of policy is taking tells you something about the grim work ethic at the top of British politics. And he comes back and he writes this diary. He says, I can see England a little clearer now. It looks in a terrible mess. It's falling apart socially as well as economically. It seems very frail compared with France, which is becoming a giant again. This is very disappointing, Tom. I mean, this is what the middle classes do, is go to France and complain that it's much better than Britain, isn't it? Yes.
他在日记中写道，他自己去法国度了一个月的假。政策负责人休假一个月，这说明了英国政治高层那糟糕的职业道德。他回来后写了这篇日记。他说，我现在能更清楚地看到英国了。它看起来一团糟。无论是在社会上还是经济上都在分崩离析。与正在重新成为巨人的法国相比，它显得非常脆弱。这太令人失望了，汤姆。我的意思是，这就是中产阶级所做的，去法国抱怨那里比英国好得多，不是吗？是的。
Is that anything unusual? I mean, they've always done it. Nelson went to France, Tom. I know, but not Nelson. After the American War of Independence was over, and he said it was awful and very poor compared with Britain. And he was middle class, and not every middle class person does it. Yeah, but to be fair, that was at the beginning of the 19th century. Yeah. And even then you had kind of Fox and- He did.
这有什么不寻常的吗？我的意思是，他们一直都这么做。纳尔逊去过法国，汤姆。我知道，但不是纳尔逊。美国独立战争结束后，他说那里很糟糕，与英国相比非常贫穷。他是中产阶级，并不是每个中产阶级都这样做。是的，但公平地说，那是19世纪初。是的。即便在那时，你也有像福克斯那样的人——他确实有。
All the Whigs complaining that Britain wasn't like France. The comparison between Roy Jenkins and Bernard Donaghy on one hand and Horatio Nelson on the other has not been made often enough, I think, in discussions of the 70s. That's what this podcast is all about. Well, talking of ludicrous stuff, actually, the whole Marcia issue is blowing up again in the summer. So it's always good to have her back on the scene. So Wilson presumably has not gone to France.
所有的辉格党人都抱怨英国不像法国。在关于70年代的讨论中，罗伊·詹金斯和伯纳德·多诺霍与霍雷肖·纳尔逊之间的比较，我认为做得还不够多。这就是这个播客的全部意义所在。嗯，说到荒谬的事情，实际上，玛西娅的问题在夏天又爆发了。所以她能回到现场总是好的。所以威尔逊大概没有去法国。
He's gone to the City Islands. City Islands, as always. And while he's been in the City Islands, this issue has been brewing of slag. The British Watergate, an amusingly banal and ludicrous scandal. So it turns out that Marcia's brother, who's a man called Tony Field, don't worry, nobody has to worry really about remembering him. He has been involved with a bouffant-haired insurance broker from Wolverhampton. There's a lot of bouffant hair around in the 70s.
他去了锡利群岛。一如既往地去了锡利群岛。当他在锡利群岛时，这个关于矿渣的问题一直在酝酿。英国的水门事件，一个令人觉得既平庸又荒谬的丑闻。原来，玛西娅的兄弟，一个叫托尼·菲尔德的人——别担心，没人需要费心记住他——他与一位来自伍尔弗汉普顿的留着蓬松发型的保险经纪人有牵连。70年代到处都是蓬松的发型。
Called Ronald Millhench. And Ronald Millhench has a scheme to buy a slag heap. Holy implausible. To buy a slag heap near Wigan and to sell it to some property developers. I mean, this is so kind of like a 1970s comic novel. It is. Absolutely it is. Like Reggie Perrin or something.
名叫罗纳德·米尔亨奇。罗纳德·米尔亨奇有一个购买矿渣堆的计划。简直不可思议。买下威根附近的一个矿渣堆，然后把它卖给一些房地产开发商。我的意思是，这太像70年代的漫画小说了。确实。绝对是。就像《雷吉·佩林》之类的。
Yeah. So he's trying to buy the slag heap. Now, the Labour Manifesto has said that they will try to crack down on people buying slag heaps, selling them off. Is this a big problem? Not a massive problem, but it's something that they just think is bad. But Milhench produces a piece of paper and he says, Howard Wilson's in on this deal and he's got Howard Wilson's signature on it.
是的。所以他试图买下那个矿渣堆。现在，工党的竞选纲领说他们会试图打击那些买卖矿渣堆的人。这是一个大问题吗？不是什么大问题，但他们只是觉得这很糟糕。但米尔亨奇拿出一张纸说，哈罗德·威尔逊参与了这笔交易，而且上面有哈罗德·威尔逊的签名。
Now, obviously, this is very implausible. And it turns out that Millhench is a fantasist, has forged a Howard Wilson's signature. But Marcia in particular, because it's her brother who's sort of semi-involved with this, she goes absolutely ballistic. And she is, having been very much on the edge since the election, she's now sort of been driven into full-scale histrionics. Donoghue's diary again. Marcia phoned HW and screamed at him saying he was a machine, not a human being. And he'd always promised that this wouldn't happen and he would protect her. She accused him of abandoning her and hiding. She was savage. She threatened to tell everything about him. And then Howard Wilson is frightened to ring her a few days later. And so he gets Bernard Donoghue to do it. And she is screaming
现在，显然，这非常不可信。结果证明米尔亨奇是个幻想家，伪造了哈罗德·威尔逊的签名。但玛西娅特别生气，因为她的兄弟与此事有某种程度的牵连，她彻底崩溃了。自从选举以来，她一直处于边缘状态，现在她被推向了全面的歇斯底里。又是多诺霍的日记。玛西娅给哈罗德·威尔逊打电话，对他尖叫，说他是个机器，不是人。他总是承诺这种情况不会发生，他会保护她。她指责他抛弃了她并躲了起来。她非常凶狠。她威胁要说出关于他的一切。然后哈罗德·威尔逊几天后不敢给她打电话。于是他让伯纳德·多诺霍去打。她在电话里对多诺霍尖叫，
at Donoghue on the phone, calling Wilson a king rat. That's what he is, a king rat. And to try and please her, he gives her a peerage and she becomes Lady Falkinder. But the weird thing about this is we see this all through the eyes of the male aides who were there in number 10, who paint her continually. So we don't have her journals? No. So what would her take on this be? I'm going to guess here that her take would be, I'm the only woman. I work with these incredibly patronizing men. They make my life very difficult. They're always laughing at me behind my back. They freeze me out.
称威尔逊为“鼠王”。他就是那样的人，一个鼠王。为了取悦她，他给了她一个贵族头衔，她成了福尔金德夫人。但奇怪的是，我们通过当时在唐宁街10号的男性助手们的眼睛看到了这一切，他们不断地描绘她。所以我们没有她的日记？没有。那么她对此会有什么看法呢？我在这里猜一下，她的看法会是：我是唯一的女性。我和这些极其傲慢的男人一起工作。他们让我的生活非常困难。他们总是在背后嘲笑我。他们排挤我。
She clearly does think they're trying to force her out and get Harold away from her. I mean, people would just have to read the stuff and make up their own minds. I mean, I get all that about kind of institutional sexism and everything. Yeah. But she behaves quite poorly, I think.
她显然认为他们正试图把她赶走，并把哈罗德从她身边带走。我的意思是，人们只需要读读这些东西，然后自己下结论。我的意思是，我明白关于制度性性别歧视等等的一切。是的。但我认为她的表现相当糟糕，汤姆。
I think calling him a... Yeah. Using that particular word. That word and everything. To describe him in public is kind of poor form i think tom and it's not just kind of one guy who's writing this they're all writing it basically they concur yeah from the people who are inside the machine as it were they agree one thing she doesn't know is that they are also yes things get to the state that they're actually
我认为称他为……是的。使用那个特定的词。那个词以及所有的一切。在公开场合这样描述他，我认为是不妥的，汤姆。而且不仅仅是一个人在写这个，他们基本上都在写，他们达成了一致。是的，从那些身处机器内部的人来看，他们同意这一点。她不知道的一件事是，他们也——是的，事情发展到了他们实际上
this will surprise some listeners they're actually planning to murder her. So after the slag heap furor, Wilson's personal doctor, who is Joseph Stone, who he later ennobles, who becomes Lord Stone, he goes in to see Joe Haynes, the press secretary. And I'm going to tell you what Haynes says about this conversation. He says, Dr. Stone asked if we could discuss ways of taking the weight of Marcia off the prime minister's mind. Stone explains that he could dispose of her in such a way that it would seem to be from natural causes. He added that he would sign the death certificate and it would not be a problem. Now, the thing is,
这会让一些听众感到惊讶，他们实际上在计划谋杀她。所以在矿渣堆风波之后，威尔逊的私人医生约瑟夫·斯通（他后来被封为斯通勋爵）进去见了新闻秘书乔·海恩斯。我要告诉你海恩斯关于这次谈话的内容。他说，斯通医生问我们是否可以讨论一些减轻首相心理负担的方法。斯通解释说，他可以处理掉她，看起来像是自然死亡。他补充说，他会签署死亡证明，这不会有问题。现在，问题是，
when Haynes tells this story, it is pretty obvious it's not a joke. I mean, he's describing it in an incredibly deadpan way, like this is the conversation that happened. So you think, well, maybe this is a one-off or whatever. But it is clear that when they went to Bonn on a prime minister visit a few weeks later, Dr. Stone again floated the idea of murdering Marcia, poisoning her, to Haynes and Donoghue. Because Donoghue writes in his diary something like a very interesting conversation with Joe. You write, I think, with immense restraint about this, that three of Wilson's most trusted aides seriously discussed murdering his political secretary,
当海恩斯讲述这个故事时，很明显这不是个玩笑。我的意思是，他以一种极其冷漠的方式描述它，就像这是真实发生的谈话一样。所以你会想，也许这是一次性的或者什么的。但很明显，几周后当他们去波恩进行首相访问时，斯通医生再次向海恩斯和多诺霍提出了谋杀玛西娅、毒死她的想法。因为多诺霍在日记中写道，类似于“与乔进行了一次非常有趣的谈话”。我想你写得非常克制，威尔逊最信任的三名助手认真讨论了谋杀他的政治秘书，
speaks volumes about the atmosphere inside Number 10 after March 1974, which is, putting it mildly, I mean, Boris has got nothing on this. No. I mean, I don't think he was plotting to murder people, was he? Maybe he was. I mean, Boris, could he murder somebody? Dominic Cummings. You could kind of imagine Dominic Cummings, perhaps, plotting to murder people. Yes. I don't know whether that's libelous, and if it is, I'll retract it unreservedly. Boris is too disorganized, surely, to murder somebody.
这充分说明了1974年3月之后唐宁街10号内部的气氛，委婉地说，我的意思是，鲍里斯在这方面根本没法比。没有。我的意思是，我不认为他在密谋谋杀别人，对吧？也许他有。我的意思是，鲍里斯，他能谋杀某人吗？多米尼克·卡明斯。你可以想象多米尼克·卡明斯也许在密谋谋杀别人。是的。我不知道这是否构成诽谤，如果是的话，我毫无保留地收回。鲍里斯太混乱了，肯定没法谋杀某人。
I mean, he would put the poison in the wrong drink or something. No, I just don't think he'd do it. I don't think he's the kind of murdering kind. He'd forget about it. Yes. So the murder plot then comes back again in December. They went to Paris to renegotiate, Tom, Britain's membership of the EEC. Oh, God. It never stops, does it?
我的意思是，他会把毒药放进错误的饮料里之类的。不，我只是不认为他会这样做。我不认为他是那种会谋杀的人。他会忘记这件事的。是的。所以谋杀阴谋在12月又出现了。他们去了巴黎重新谈判，汤姆，英国加入欧共体的成员资格。哦，天哪。它永远不会停止，不是吗？
Right? Yeah. Marcia sent a message to Wilson in the conference room to say she heard her brother was ill and Wilson must come back with her at once to London. This is the brother who's been hanging out with the bouffant-haired slag guy. Slag guy. I mean, imagine, you know, Wilson is sitting around the table with the leaders of Europe negotiating Britain's place in the EC. And at that point, Dr. Stone again says to Donoghue, listen, we should think about putting her down. But Haynes, whatever Marcia had done,
对吧？是的。玛西娅给会议室里的威尔逊传了个口信，说她听说她兄弟病了，威尔逊必须立刻和她一起回伦敦。这就是那个一直和留着蓬松发型的矿渣男混在一起的兄弟。矿渣男。我的意思是，想象一下，你知道，威尔逊正坐在桌边与欧洲领导人谈判英国在欧共体中的地位。就在那时，斯通医生又对多诺霍说，听着，我们应该考虑除掉她。但海恩斯，无论玛西娅做了什么，
he wrote earnestly, she didn't deserve that kind of end. I know. And I don't think you would write that if it was all just a great joke. Haynes says very seriously, I couldn't stand Marcia, but I didn't think we should murder her. So yes, this is a pretty extraordinary moment in British politics. Wilson is absolutely shattered. He's miserable. He's getting harangued by everybody. And what's also interesting, Tom, is that it's at this point, I think, that Wilson starts to become understandably paranoid. So he has always been fascinated by the world of intelligence and the secret services. I mean, he has a little sort of
他认真地写道，她不应该有那样的结局。我知道。而且我不认为如果这只是个大玩笑，你会那样写。海恩斯非常严肃地说，我受不了玛西娅，但我不认为我们应该谋杀她。所以是的，这是英国政治中一个非常非凡的时刻。威尔逊彻底崩溃了。他很痛苦。他被所有人训斥。而且有趣的是，汤姆，我认为正是在这一点上，威尔逊开始变得可以理解地偏执。所以他一直对情报世界和秘密服务着迷。我的意思是，他有一个小小的
fixation with it. I mean, lots of us are interested in this, right? We like to think of this as a secret world and we're fascinated by it. Well, it's a kind of a solution, isn't it? If there are shadowy figures in the wings plotting against you, then it might explain why things are going badly. Now, the thing is, the security services have always been interested themselves in Harold Wilson. So we know now that they opened a file on him as early as 1945. He was codenamed Norman John Worthington. And so what brought him to their attention was that they had heard a civil servant praising him, a communist civil servant, so they'd opened this file. And then Wilson, when he was president of the Board of Trade in the 1940s, had made a series of trips to Moscow, where he obviously came into contact with communist officials. Later on, he became consultant to a firm that imported timber. And again, he was meeting a lot of people who were senior Soviet officials, a couple of whom were almost certainly KGB officers working
执念。我的意思是，我们很多人都对这个感兴趣，对吧？我们喜欢把它看作一个秘密世界，我们对它着迷。嗯，这是一种解决方案，不是吗？如果幕后有阴影人物在密谋反对你，那么这可能解释了为什么事情进展不顺。现在，问题是，安全部门本身一直对哈罗德·威尔逊很感兴趣。所以我们现在知道，他们早在1945年就为他建立了档案。他的代号是诺曼·约翰·沃辛顿。引起他们注意的原因是，他们听到了一位公务员在称赞他，一位共产主义公务员，所以他们建立了这个档案。然后威尔逊在40年代担任贸易委员会主席时，曾多次前往莫斯科，在那里他显然与共产主义官员有了接触。后来，他成为了一家进口木材公司的顾问。同样，他会见了很多高级苏联官员，其中有几个人几乎肯定是为苏联大使馆工作的克格勃官员。
at the Soviet embassy. That was not massively out of the ordinary at the time, but he also has a very strange coterie of friends. So they're often kind of Eastern European Jews. So there's a fair bit of antisemitism kind of hanging over all this. They are sort of shady tycoons. So there's a guy called Joseph Kagan, who's a raincoat tycoon. Yes, yes, that's right. And that's the Ganex Max. Yeah, Ganex Max. Yeah, we've already mentioned.
这在当时并不算太出格，但他还有一群非常奇怪的朋友。所以他们通常是东欧犹太人。所以这一切中悬着相当多的反犹太主义。他们是某种阴暗的大亨。所以有一个叫约瑟夫·卡根的人，是个雨衣大亨。是的，是的，没错。那就是“加内克斯·麦克斯”。是的，加内克斯·麦克斯。是的，我们已经提到了。
The publisher, Robert Maxwell, who will be well known to a lot of our British listeners. And indeed to American listeners, because he's the father of- Oh, Ghislaine. The Prince Andrew- Epstein associate. Exactly. So Wilson has all these friends, which actually baffle a lot of his political contemporaries. I think Wilson has these friends because they are rich and they pay for him to go on trips and things. And they're very
出版商罗伯特·麦克斯韦，很多英国听众都很熟悉他。当然也包括美国听众，因为他是——哦，吉斯莱恩的父亲。那个安德鲁王子——爱泼斯坦的同伙。没错。所以威尔逊有所有这些朋友，这实际上让他的许多政治同僚感到困惑。我认为威尔逊有这些朋友是因为他们很有钱，而且他们付钱让他去旅行之类的事情。而且他们是非常
undemanding and sycophantic company because they want him for favors and things. So he plays golf with them. He hangs out with them. It's a nice break from hanging around with other politicians. But it does look dodgy. Now, there are some people in the security services who think all this is so dodgy that Howard Wilson is probably something weird going on here. And the key man for this is an old friend of the rest of his history, Tom. The alumnus of your old school. A fellow old Malvernian. Yes.
不苛求且谄媚的伙伴，因为他们想从他那里得到好处。所以他和他们打高尔夫球。他和他们混在一起。这比和其他政客混在一起是个不错的休息。但这看起来很可疑。现在，安全部门里有些人认为这一切太可疑了，哈罗德·威尔逊可能有什么奇怪的事情发生。而关键人物是《剩下的就是历史》的一位老朋友，汤姆。你母校的校友。一位老马尔文人。是的。
Our old friend, James Jesus Angleton, the CIA counterintelligence chief. Yeah. So by the mid-1970s, Angleton, there's a lot of people who've gone mad in this podcast, aren't there? Yeah. Well, because he thinks everyone's a spy, right? Angleton believes that the KGB moles active in Western politics include Harold Wilson, the Canadian Prime Minister, Lester Pearson, the Chancellor of West Germany, Willy Brandt, Henry Kissinger, he thinks is a communist agent,
我们的老朋友，詹姆斯·耶稣·安格尔顿，中情局反间谍主管。是的。所以到了70年代中期，安格尔顿——这个播客里有很多疯了的人，不是吗？是的。嗯，因为他认为每个人都是间谍，对吧？安格尔顿认为活跃在西方政治中的克格勃鼹鼠包括哈罗德·威尔逊、加拿大总理莱斯特·皮尔逊、西德总理维利·勃兰特、亨利·基辛格，他认为他是共产主义特工，
as indeed is Gerald Ford. But Gerald Ford plays golf. He couldn't have been a communist. No. Well, he's not a communist. I mean, I'm going to go on the record here, Tom. I don't think Gerald Ford was working for the KGB. So Angleton, whenever he goes to Britain, says to people in MI5 and MI6, you know, you've got a communist as your prime minister. And actually, one guy who believes him is a man called Peter Wright, who is this rogue MI5 agent who ended up writing a book in the 80s called Spycatcher, in which he claims that he and 30 MI5 officers had been conspiring against Wilson in the 70s.
杰拉尔德·福特也是。但杰拉尔德·福特打高尔夫球。他不可能是一个共产主义者。不。嗯，他不是共产主义者。我的意思是，我要在这里记录在案，汤姆。我不认为杰拉尔德·福特在为克格勃工作。所以安格尔顿每次去英国，都会对军情五处和军情六处的人说，你知道，你们有一位共产主义者作为首相。实际上，有一个相信他的人叫彼得·赖特，他是那个流氓军情五处特工，他在80年代写了一本叫《间谍捕手》的书，他在书中声称他和30名军情五处官员在70年代一直在密谋反对威尔逊。
Now, when people started to investigate Wright's story, they asked him questions and said, was it really 30? There were 30 of you. He said, well, it was more like three. And then he was asked, how many people actively joined you in trying to campaign against Harold Wilson? He said, well, one, I should say. So it's not quite as big a plot as you would think. But the idea that Wilson is a secret KGB agent definitely seeps into sort of Westminster gossip and Fleet Street gossip in the early 70s. And Wilson is alert to it? Wilson absolutely is alert to it. So Wilson is aware that, for example, Private Eye magazine, which you began with, the satirical
现在，当人们开始调查赖特的故事时，他们问他问题，说，真的是30个吗？你们有30个人。他说，嗯，更像是三个。然后有人问他，有多少人积极加入你试图反对哈罗德·威尔逊的运动？他说，嗯，我想说一个。所以这并不像你想象的那么大的阴谋。但威尔逊是秘密克格勃特工的想法确实在70年代初渗入了威斯敏斯特的八卦和舰队街的八卦中。而威尔逊对此保持警惕？威尔逊绝对保持警惕。所以威尔逊意识到，例如，你开头提到的《私家侦探》杂志，那本讽刺
magazine. The Sniggering Public School Boys. Is every two weeks publishing stories that basically allege that Wilson is working for the KGB. So their diarist, Auburn Waugh, he says explicitly, I've never attempted to hide my belief that Harold Wislon, recruited in Moscow and London in 1956 as a Soviet agent. Yeah, but Dominic, Auburn Waugh, he's the son of Evelyn Waugh. Yes.
杂志。那些窃笑的公立学校男生。每两周发表的故事基本上都声称威尔逊在为克格勃工作。所以他们的日记作者奥本·沃，他明确表示，我从未试图隐藏我的信念，即哈罗德·威尔逊于1956年在莫斯科和伦敦被招募为苏联特工。是的，但多米尼克，奥本·沃，他是伊夫林·沃的儿子。是的。
I mean, he's a comic writer. Yeah. That diary, I mean, it wasn't serious. No. He used it to have a go at his enemies, of which he had many, but- I think he puts in his biography in Who's Who is his hobby, telling lies. Yeah. But, Tom, it's cumulative.
我的意思是，他是个喜剧作家。是的。那篇日记，我的意思是，那不是认真的。不。他用它来攻击他的敌人，他有很多敌人，但是——我想他在《名人录》的传记中把他的爱好写成“撒谎”。是的。但是，汤姆，这是累积的。
It's not just an Auburn Waugh's diary. It's everywhere in Private Eye, and it kind of is simmering under the surface in all of these slightly paranoid right-wing predictions of a communist takeover of Britain, the claims that the high tax rates are the beginning of a move towards, you used the expression, the pauperization of the middle classes. That is an absolutely standard right-wing theme in mid-70s. So the idea of moles. Yes.
这不仅仅是奥本·沃的日记。它在《私家侦探》中随处可见，而且在所有这些关于共产主义接管英国的略带偏执的右翼预测中，在那些高税率是迈向——你用了那个表达——中产阶级贫困化的开始的说法中，它都在表面下酝酿。这是70年代中期绝对标准的右翼主题。所以关于鼹鼠的想法。是的。
Is this when Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy comes out, the Le Carre novel? It is. Which features a mole, doesn't it? It is. And that is the ultimate 1974 novel. It's published in the summer of 1974. So just after Wilson has returned. Oh God, so it's come out just at this time. The plot of it is the return of a sort of podgy little man, sort of knackered, aging, clever man in a battered old Mac with a complicated marital relationship.
这是《锅匠，裁缝，士兵，间谍》那部勒卡雷小说出版的时候吗？是的。里面有一个鼹鼠，不是吗？是的。那是1974年的终极小说。它出版于1974年夏天。所以就在威尔逊回来之后。哦，天哪，所以它就在这个时候出来了。它的情节是一个矮胖的小个子男人的回归，某种精疲力竭、衰老、聪明、穿着破旧雨衣、婚姻关系复杂的男人。
It was George Smiley, but he kind of looks and sounds very like Wilson. The portrait of the Secret Service, its morale has been corroded by office politics and budget cuts and this incredibly toxic culture of feuding and suspicion. The descriptions of the headquarters of the Secret Service, the circus, as John le Carré calls it, the wallpaper peeling, the phones not working, the lift not working, everything a total shambles. The portrait of London as this dilapidated city. 1974 is also the year that you have David Bowie's Diamond Dogs, James Herbert's The Rats, Martin Amis is writing Dead Babies, J.G. Ballard is writing High Rise. There is this sort of sense that the nation has entered a point of terminal irreversible decline, that Wilson himself is the personification of that. And actually, if you don't get him out,
那是乔治·斯迈利，但他看起来和听起来都很像威尔逊。对秘密服务的描绘，其士气被办公室政治、预算削减以及这种极其有毒的争斗和怀疑文化所腐蚀。对秘密服务总部的描述，约翰·勒卡雷称之为“马戏团”，墙纸剥落，电话不工作，电梯不工作，一切都是一团糟。对伦敦作为这座破败城市的描绘。1974年也是大卫·鲍伊的《钻石狗》、詹姆斯·赫伯特的《老鼠》、马丁·艾米斯写《死婴》、J.G.巴拉德写《摩天大楼》的一年。有一种感觉，国家已经进入了一个终极的、不可逆转的衰退点，威尔逊本人就是这种衰退的化身。实际上，如果你不把他赶走，
you're sunk. So in a situation like actually, if you don't get him out, you're sunk. So in a situation like that, if you are very right wing and perhaps with a military background and prone to hanging out late in a gentleman's club with a brandy, the obvious solution is to stage a coup, right? Yes, I suppose so. So people at the time, by the summer of 1974, you really start to notice this in the winter, the previous winter during the period of the implosion of the Heath government and the oil shock and the three-day week. But in the summer of 1974, you have in people's diaries, in the newspapers, loads of talk about ungovernability, law and order breaking down, and the inevitable emergence of a right-wing figure to take over. Now, this now sounds mad to us, right? So a lot of people listening to this will be thinking, well, there was no coup in Britain in the 70s. There was no dictatorship. But at the time,
你就完了。所以在那种情况下，如果你非常右翼，也许有军事背景，并且倾向于在绅士俱乐部里喝着白兰地待到很晚，显而易见的解决方案就是发动政变，对吧？是的，我想是这样。所以当时的人们，到1974年夏天，你真的开始注意到这一点，在前一个冬天，在希思政府崩溃、石油冲击和三日工作制期间。但在1974年夏天，你在人们的日记里、报纸里，到处都是关于无法治理、法律和秩序崩溃以及右翼人物不可避免地出现来接管的谈话。现在，这听起来对我们来说很疯狂，对吧？所以很多听着这个的人会想，嗯，70年代英国没有政变。没有独裁。但在当时，
it didn't seem mad, not just because of the precedent we mentioned already of Allende and Pinochet, but actually there's a very good precedent in Britain for law and order breaking down and the army stepping in. And that is, of course, Northern Ireland. It has happened in part of the United Kingdom. So we mentioned before, there have been troops on the streets of Northern Ireland since 1969 because of the sectarian violence between Protestants and Catholics. There were, at their peak, more than 20,000 British troops on the streets in this relatively small, underpopulated corner of the United Kingdom. There are a lot of deaths, 480 in 1972, 255 in 1973, and almost 300 in 1974. They have brought in internment without
这看起来并不疯狂，不仅是因为我们已经提到的阿连德和皮诺切特的先例，而且实际上英国有一个非常好的法律和秩序崩溃、军队介入的先例。那就是，当然，北爱尔兰。它已经在联合王国的一部分发生了。所以我们之前提到过，自1969年以来，由于新教徒和天主教徒之间的宗派暴力，北爱尔兰街头一直有军队。在高峰期，在这个相对较小、人口稀少的联合王国角落，街头有超过20,000名英国士兵。死亡人数很多，1972年有480人，1973年有255人，1974年有近300人。他们引入了未经
trial. The Parliament of Northern Ireland was shut down in 1972 because the Heath government thought that it was unable to command the loyalty of the Catholic population. And they've replaced it by direct rule from Westminster with the aid of the army. So all of that is a sort of a very bad precedent. Now, in the final months of the Heath government, Heath, working with the Republic of Ireland, working with different parties in Northern Ireland, had set up a power sharing executive. So with elements of both Catholics and Protestants, and there was a Council of Ireland with the Republic of Ireland, and this was under the Sunningdale Agreement.
审判的拘留。北爱尔兰议会在1972年被关闭，因为希思政府认为它无法指挥天主教人口的忠诚。他们用军队的协助，以威斯敏斯特的直接统治取代了它。所以所有这些都是一个非常糟糕的先例。现在，在希思政府的最后几个月里，希思与爱尔兰共和国合作，与北爱尔兰的不同政党合作，建立了一个权力分享行政机构。所以有天主教徒和新教徒的成员，并且在桑宁代尔协议下有一个与爱尔兰共和国的爱尔兰理事会。
And this was basically the new system that was going to steer northern ireland towards peace and prosperity and actually what happens is there is an upsurge of loyalist violence against the power sharing executive you astonish me and then in may 1974 a group that no one had previously heard of called the ulster workers council that was linked to a couple of paramilitary groups the vanguard paramilitary group and the largest paramilitary group in the world at the time, which is the Ulster Defence Association, a loyalist group. They called a general strike to shut down the power sharing executive. Oh, and this is the one where Wilson goes and does his broadcast.
这基本上是引导北爱尔兰走向和平与繁荣的新系统，实际上发生的是针对权力分享行政机构的保皇派暴力激增。你让我感到惊讶，然后在1974年5月，一个以前没人听说过的组织，叫阿尔斯特工人委员会，它与几个准军事组织有关联，即先锋准军事组织和当时世界上最大的准军事组织，即阿尔斯特防卫协会，一个保皇派组织。他们发动了一场总罢工来关闭权力分享行政机构。哦，这就是威尔逊去发表广播的那一次。
Caused them sponges. Yes. And loyalists would wear sponges in their lapels to mock Wilson. So they set up barricades in the streets of Belfast, armed men. I mean, this is in the United Kingdom, Tom, in our lifetime. Armed men went to factories, shut the factories down. Armed men went to shops and shut them down. After two days, the Ulster Workers' Council had basically shut the whole of Belfast down. They blocked supermarkets. They controlled the city.
称他们为“海绵”。是的，保皇派会在翻领上戴上海绵来嘲笑威尔逊。所以他们在贝尔法斯特街头设置了路障，武装人员。我的意思是，这是在联合王国，汤姆，在我们有生之年。武装人员去工厂，关闭了工厂。武装人员去商店，把它们关了。两天后，阿尔斯特工人委员会基本上关闭了整个贝尔法斯特。他们封锁了超市。他们控制了城市。
They distributed milk. They had taken over the power station, so there were six-hour power cuts. The army, I mentioned the army are there. The army do not step in to stop them. Their argument is, if we do that, we will be fighting a war on two fronts. We'll be fighting both the Republican terrorists, the IRA and so on, and we'll also be fighting the loyalists as well. In the middle of all that, there is the single worst attack of the whole troubles when the Yalster Volunteer Force set off car bombs in Dublin and monaghan across the border in the republic of
他们分发牛奶。他们接管了发电站，所以有六小时的停电。军队，我提到过军队在那里。军队没有介入阻止他们。他们的论点是，如果我们那样做，我们将会在两条战线上作战。我们将同时与共和党恐怖分子、爱尔兰共和军等作战，我们也将与保皇派作战。在所有这些中间，发生了整个动乱中最糟糕的一次袭击，当时阿尔斯特志愿军在边境对面的爱尔兰共和国都柏林和莫纳汉引爆了汽车炸弹，
ireland they killed 34 people and injured hundreds more absolutely horrific horrific scenes so that's in the middle of all that the strike lasted for 14 days and the paramilitaries and the strikers won at the end of may 1974 the entire power sharing resigned. Stormont was shut down. Britain resumed direct rule over Northern Ireland. And you have these scenes of huge bonfires burning in loyalist areas of Belfast. And so a lot of people, remember we said before, most people in Britain are not actually that bothered about Northern Ireland. They don't really care. But this is one occasion when it is on the front page of every newspaper day after day and the government lost. They were humiliated. The army
他们杀死了34人，炸伤了数百人，场面绝对恐怖，恐怖。所以就在所有这些中间，罢工持续了14天，准军事组织和罢工者赢了。1974年5月底，整个权力分享机构辞职。斯托蒙特被关闭。英国恢复了对北爱尔兰的直接统治。你看到了贝尔法斯特保皇派地区燃起巨大篝火的场景。所以很多人，记得我们之前说的，英国的大多数人实际上并不太关心北爱尔兰。他们并不真正关心。但这是一个它日复一日出现在每份报纸头版的机会，政府输了。他们受到了羞辱。军队
humiliated. They did nothing to stop it. As it were, mob violence had completely and utterly prevailed. And a lot of people say the conservative classes, they absolutely think this is a preview of what is coming to Britain. Masked men with guns. Because on the right, there's the spectacle of what effectively is a kind of militant strike in Ulster. Does that blur with their anxieties about what might happen with the unions in Britain? Exactly. They say, this is how it will happen. This is how the general strike will happen in Britain. Because don't forget, they have had power cuts. They have had the interruption of supplies. They've had all of these things. And they say, my God, this is the template. This is what will happen. And of course,
受到了羞辱。他们什么也没做来阻止它。可以说，暴民暴力已经完全彻底地占了上风。很多人说，保守阶层，他们绝对认为这是英国即将发生的事情的预演。戴着面具拿着枪的人。因为在右翼，有阿尔斯特那种实际上是某种激进罢工的景象。这是否与他们对英国工会可能发生的事情的焦虑混在一起了？没错。他们说，这就是它将如何发生。这就是英国总罢工将如何发生。因为别忘了，他们经历过停电。他们经历过供应中断。他们经历过所有这些事情。他们说，天哪，这就是模板。这就是将会发生的事情。当然，
people on the left say, this is the template for a right-wing coup. So everybody sees in it something to match their nightmares. Right. So on the right, people are saying, Tony Benn, he is Stalin. He wants to bring in five-year plans and send people off to re-education camps. And meanwhile, Tony Benn himself is expecting the army is going to come and arrest him at any minute, isn't he? He is indeed. There's kind of a lot of worry that the army is preparing a coup. So is there anyone in the army preparing a coup? Is there an equivalent in the higher echelons of the British army of a Peter Wright in the Secret Services?
左翼的人说，这是右翼政变的模板。所以每个人都在其中看到了符合他们噩梦的东西。对。所以右翼的人说，托尼·本，他是斯大林。他想引入五年计划，把人们送去再教育营。与此同时，托尼·本本人正在期待军队随时会来逮捕他，不是吗？他确实是。有一种担心，军队正在准备政变。那么军队里有人在准备政变吗？在英国军队的高层中，是否有彼得·赖特在秘密服务中的对应人物？
Okay. So first of all, the army do intervene in British politics multiple times in the 70s. So of course the army, I mean, they're trying to stay out of Northern Irish politics, but they are inevitably embedded in it since they arrived in Northern Ireland in 1969. But in the course of the 70s, the army actually intervened in British industrial disputes on 12 different occasions. I mean, the most famous one, which older listeners will remember, is they drove fire engines towards the end of the decade, the green goddesses, as they were called, when the firemen went out on strike. They provide cover for people who collect bins, for ambulance drivers and things. So the army are being dragged into politics. And in 1971, a guy called Frank Kitson, a brigadier who had commanded in Cyprus and Malaya, among other places, and Kenya, and who also commanded troops in Northern Ireland, he actually wrote a blueprint
好的。首先，军队在70年代多次介入英国政治。所以当然军队，我的意思是，他们试图远离北爱尔兰政治，但自1969年他们到达北爱尔兰以来，他们不可避免地嵌入其中。但在70年代的过程中，军队实际上在12个不同的场合介入了英国的劳资纠纷。我的意思是，最著名的一次，老听众会记得，是他们在十年末驾驶消防车，也就是所谓的“绿色女神”，当时消防员罢工了。他们为收集垃圾的人、救护车司机等提供掩护。所以军队正被拖入政治。而在1971年，一个叫弗兰克·基特森的人，一位曾在塞浦路斯、马来亚等地以及肯尼亚指挥过，并且也在北爱尔兰指挥过部队的准将，他实际上写了一份蓝图
called Low Intensity Operations, Subversion, Insurgency and Peacekeeping. So a low intensity operation is very... Yes, chilling. And he said, we need to prepare people to take part in operations against political extremists here in Britain. We need to have specialist units that will run railway stations, power stations, sewage works, supervised miners, and all this kind of thing. This is coming. So to be clear, this is not a blueprint for a coup. He's not talking about launching a coup.
叫《低强度作战：颠覆、叛乱和维和》。所以低强度作战是非常……是的，令人不寒而栗。他说，我们需要让人们准备好参与针对英国国内政治极端分子的行动。我们需要有专门的部队来运营火车站、发电站、污水处理厂，监督矿工，以及所有这类事情。这就要来了。所以要明确一点，这不是政变的蓝图。他不是在谈论发动政变。
But I guess you could say the germ of the idea of army involvement in everyday political and industrial life is absolutely there and has been since the beginning of the seventies. What they need, I mean, if you're in your gentleman's club, right? And you're drinking a brand, you know, saying Wilson is a communist, what you need is a figurehead. You know, you need the dictator. So who is that? Well, there is such a person, Tom. This is the thing. Brilliant. General Sir Walter Walker. So General
但我猜你可以说，军队参与日常政治和工业生活的想法的萌芽绝对存在，并且自70年代初以来就一直存在。他们需要的是，我的意思是，如果你在你的绅士俱乐部里，对吧？你喝着白兰地，你知道，说威尔逊是共产主义者，你需要的是一个领袖。你知道，你需要那个独裁者。那么那是谁呢？确实有这样一个人，汤姆。就是这样。太棒了。沃尔特·沃克将军。所以沃尔特·沃克
Sir Walter Walker is from a military family. He's in his 60s. His grandfather had been decorated in the Indian mutiny, Tom. His father had been in India. He himself, he was Britain's leading jungle commander. So he had led troops in Malaya and Borneo. So crushing communists. Crushing communists in the 50s. He's very popular with his men. Having a crack at the Reds. He'd ended up as commander-in-chief, Allied forces, Northern Europe. So he's a big cheese in the military world,
爵士来自一个军事家庭。他60多岁了。他的祖父在印度兵变中获得过勋章，汤姆。他的父亲曾在印度。他自己，他是英国领先的丛林指挥官。所以他在马来亚和婆罗洲领导过部队。所以镇压共产主义者。在50年代镇压共产主义者。他很受部下欢迎。和“红军”较量。他最终成为了盟军北欧部队的总司令。所以他是军事世界里的大人物，
but he's gutted that he doesn't get more respect in Britain. Because people aren't as interested in the military in Britain in the 60s, 70s as they were. And Dominic, does he have a positive attitude towards gay rights? I knew you'd go for this, Tom. He's a little bit perturbed it's fair to say by the social changes of the
但他很沮丧，因为他在英国没有得到更多的尊重。因为人们在60、70年代对英国军队不像以前那么感兴趣了。多米尼克，他对同性恋权利有积极的态度吗？我就知道你会问这个，汤姆。他有点不安，公平地说，因为他所看到的
1960s as he sees them so yes he says that gay people use the main sewer of the human body as a playground which i think is um right wouldn't go down well in today's you know much more touchy feely uh british high command were. Yes, as it were. And he also has very strong views on Northern Ireland because he says, I don't know why we're going on so weak in Northern Ireland. We should just go in and crush them. So we should treat white people like everybody else.
1960年代的社会变化，所以是的，他说同性恋者把人体的主要下水道当作游乐场，我认为这……嗯，在今天这种更敏感的英国高层中可能不会受欢迎。是的，确实如此。而且他对北爱尔兰也有非常强烈的看法，因为他说，我不知道为什么我们在北爱尔兰表现得如此软弱。我们应该直接进去镇压他们。所以我们应该像对待其他人一样对待白人。
Like everybody else. So in a sense, he's a woke right-wing dictator. He is a woke dictator. He does say he'd give people warnings. This is about Northern Ireland. I give them a warning so they can get their women and children away before we go in, but we should go in. So, I mean, God knows where people would get their women and children to, but anyway. right-wing organizations. I imagine the meeting in the vast and underheated dining rooms of seedy gentlemen's clubs, St. James' gentlemen's clubs. And he's backed by somebody called Paul Daniels, isn't he? The magician.
像对待其他人一样。所以从某种意义上说，他是一个“觉醒”的右翼独裁者。他是一个“觉醒”的独裁者。他确实说他会给人们警告。这是关于北爱尔兰的。我给他们一个警告，这样他们就可以在我们要进去之前把妇女和儿童带走，但我们应该进去。所以，我的意思是，天知道人们会把他们的妇女和儿童带到哪里去，但无论如何。右翼组织。我想象在破旧的绅士俱乐部、圣詹姆斯绅士俱乐部那巨大且供暖不足的餐厅里举行的会议。他是由一个叫保罗·丹尼尔斯的人支持的，不是吗？那个魔术师。
Not the magician. He's chairman of the British military volunteer force, I'm reading. A tiny group of ex-servicemen who sent volunteers to the conga in the yemen and um he's fake about the nature of britain's economic problems but to quote you thought pornography had something to do with it yeah so i mean these do not sound like serious people really no although so by the middle of 1974 there were letters and columns in the broadsheets week after week about General Swalter Walker and his plans. He's become associated with a very cranky sort of right-wing organization called Unison, which says it's going to be a vigilante group. Because that sounds like a union. Well, there is a union called Unison now. Yeah.
不是那个魔术师。我读到他是英国志愿军的主席。这是一个由退伍军人组成的小团体，曾向刚果和也门派遣志愿者。嗯，他对英国经济问题的本质看法很荒谬，但引用你的话，你认为色情制品与此有关，是吗？所以，我的意思是，这些人听起来并不像严肃的人。虽然在1974年中期，大报上每周都有关于沃尔特·沃克将军及其计划的信件和专栏文章。他与一个名为Unison的非常古怪的右翼组织联系在一起，该组织声称自己是一个治安维持团体。因为这听起来像是一个工会。嗯，现在确实有一个叫Unison的工会。是的。
So they said, let's set up a vigilante group to fight the inevitable communist takeover. And General Swalter Walker is always writing these group to fight the inevitable communist takeover. And General Sir Walter Walker is always writing these excellent letters to the Daily Telegraph. The communist Trojan horse is in our midst with its fellow travelers wriggling their maggoty way inside its belly. And he says, listen, it's coming. Wilson isn't going to be able to turn this around. And he's a communist anyway. The the crisis is coming you're going to have to choose unbelievably he says uh i hope people will choose rule by the gun in preference to anarchy it's very rare that people say i'd like the thought of rule by the gun yes yes he clearly thinks this is a massive selling point the terrible thing is tom there might have been a civil war because he had a rival and his rival was uh like you a scottish laird
所以他们说，让我们建立一个治安维持团体来对抗不可避免的共产主义接管。沃尔特·沃克爵士总是给《每日电讯报》写这些出色的信件。共产主义的特洛伊木马就在我们中间，它的同路人正蠕动着钻进它的肚子里。他说，听着，它要来了。威尔逊无法扭转局面。而且他本身就是个共产主义者。危机即将来临，你们将不得不做出选择。令人难以置信的是，他说，我希望人们选择枪杆子统治，而不是无政府状态。很少有人会说我喜欢枪杆子统治的想法。是的，他显然认为这是一个巨大的卖点。可怕的是，汤姆，可能真的会发生内战，因为他有一个竞争对手，而他的对手和你一样，是一位苏格兰地主。
right so this is a guy called uh colonel david sterling oh yes yes the founder of the sas yeah he was in the bbc drama where they rush around the desert uh slamming music really okay well i'll take your word for it yeah i can't remember what it was called. It was on recently. Okay. Brilliant details. Thanks for that. Rogue Heroes, Theo says in the chat. That's it.
对，这是一个叫大卫·斯特林上校的人。哦，是的，SAS的创始人。是的，他出现在BBC的电视剧里，他们在沙漠里跑来跑去，砰砰地放音乐。好吧，我听你的。是的，我不记得那叫什么了。最近才播的。好的。精彩的细节。谢谢。西奥在聊天中说是《无名英雄》。就是那个。
Yes. Anyway, David Sterling has set up his own little organization called GB75. And this is leaked to The Guardian. And they interviewed David Sterling about it. And he said, oh, this is basically a group of apprehensive patriots. We've come together because when there's a general strike, when there's this Ulster Workers' Council strike happens in Britain, we will take over the power stations to keep everybody's lights on. Now, Sterling, unlike Walter Walker, is actually quite publicity shy. So he's very embarrassed when this is leaked. Whereas Walter Walker is going mad and telling people that he has 13 million recruits, which is about 12,999,099, too many, more than he has. David
是的。总之，大卫·斯特林成立了他自己的小组织，叫GB75。这被泄露给了《卫报》。他们采访了大卫·斯特林，他说，哦，这基本上是一群忧心忡忡的爱国者。我们聚在一起是因为当大罢工发生时，当阿尔斯特工人委员会在英国发动罢工时，我们将接管发电站以保持电力供应。现在，斯特林与沃尔特·沃克不同，他实际上相当害羞，不喜欢抛头露面。所以当这件事被泄露时，他非常尴尬。而沃尔特·沃克则陷入疯狂，告诉人们他有1300万名新兵，这比他实际拥有的人数多了大约12999099人。大卫
Sterling is very embarrassed and he goes very quiet after all this comes out. But obviously, in the minds of people, particularly on the left, this hits home. So Harold Wilson is always going on about this with his aides. Even a couple of years later, they read a story in the newspapers in number 10 that some British mercenaries had been executed in Angola. And Bernard Donaghy writes in his diary, he was completely taken up with this question of Angolan mercenaries. He's genuinely petrified of a right-wing coup in Britain using ex-servicemen as the shock troops. Since there are few troops based in the UK, they could, he believes, carry out a coup d'etat. Now, a man in the pub talking about Angolan mercenaries taking over Britain, that happens. The prime minister talking about it is sort of disturbing. And actually,
斯特林非常尴尬，在这一切曝光后变得非常安静。但显然，在人们的心中，特别是在左翼人士的心中，这触动了他们的神经。所以哈罗德·威尔逊总是和他的助手们谈论这件事。甚至几年后，他们在唐宁街10号的报纸上读到一则故事，说一些英国雇佣兵在安哥拉被处决了。伯纳德·多纳希在他的日记中写道，他完全被安哥拉雇佣兵的问题所困扰。他真的非常害怕英国会发生右翼政变，利用退伍军人作为突击部队。由于驻扎在英国的军队很少，他认为他们可以发动政变。现在，酒吧里的人谈论安哥拉雇佣兵接管英国，这很常见。但首相谈论这件事就有点令人不安了。实际上，
what all this is, I think, like all the Tonyony ben stuff like all of this even to some extent like they're mad histrionics about who's having lunch in number 10 all this is clearly a sign of a deep political sickness in britain in the mid 70s and i don't think that's me just projecting my own interpretation onto it i think you see that reflected. I mean, it doesn't matter what people in the opposition think, but people within the government itself. So your Dennis Healy's, your Roy Jenkins's, Barbara Castle, Tony Benn, all these people who write diaries and brilliant autobiographies at the time, because they're an exceptionally literate and well-educated group who have taken control of British politics. They think something
这一切，我认为，就像所有托尼·本的事情一样，甚至在某种程度上，就像他们对谁在唐宁街10号吃午餐的疯狂歇斯底里一样，这一切显然是70年代中期英国政治深层疾病的征兆。我不认为这只是我将自己的解读投射到上面，我认为你看到了这种反映。我的意思是，反对派的想法并不重要，但政府内部的人，比如丹尼斯·希利、罗伊·詹金斯、芭芭拉·卡斯尔、托尼·本，所有这些在当时写日记和精彩自传的人，因为他们是一群受过良好教育、控制了英国政治的精英。他们认为事情
is seriously, deeply wrong. And the question is, can it be turned around? And is Howard Wilson remotely the man to do it, especially as he leads a minority government? And so the tension is sort of mounting and mounting and mounting. And then on the 18th of September, 1974, Wilson says, okay, fine, let's do this. Let's have a second general election to end the uncertainty and to give the country a definitive direction. So he says, I'm going to have a fourth showdown with Ted Heath, winner takes all, to decide the future of the country. Tom, an incredible cliffhanger to end the episode.
严重地、深刻地出了问题。问题是，它能被扭转吗？哈罗德·威尔逊是做这件事的人吗？尤其是他领导的是一个少数派政府？所以紧张局势在不断升级。然后在1974年9月18日，威尔逊说，好吧，就这样吧。让我们进行第二次大选，以结束不确定性，并给国家一个明确的方向。所以他说，我要和泰德·希思进行第四次对决，胜者全得，以决定国家的未来。汤姆，这是一个令人难以置信的悬念，结束了这一集。
So will he manage it? Will he end up with a larger mandate in his hand? Only one way to find out. And that is by tuning into our next episode, which will be out either tomorrow, or if you are a member of the Restless History Club, you've already got it. So huge excitement. Yeah. There are two ways to find out and in fact i can't believe that anybody listening to that amazing cliffhanger would not join the rest is history club immediately you'd be mad yeah you'd be mad not to not least because one of the great perks of joining the rest is history club is if you do join we will train you in how to run a power station in the event of a crippling 1970s-style general strike. So exciting.
那么他能成功吗？他最终会获得更大的授权吗？只有一个办法可以知道。那就是收听我们的下一集，它将在明天发布，或者如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”的成员，你已经收到了。所以非常令人兴奋。是的。有两种方法可以知道，事实上，我无法相信任何听到那个惊人悬念的人不会立即加入“历史其余部分俱乐部”，你会疯掉的。是的，如果不加入你就是疯了。不仅因为加入“历史其余部分俱乐部”的一大福利是，如果你加入，我们将培训你如何在1970年代式的大罢工中运营发电站。太令人兴奋了。
All right. So next episode, the second election of 1974. Bye-bye. Bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的。那么下一集，1974年的第二次选举。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。